okay we're recording and we're almost at
the battery so we don't know how long
this video is going to last um Cheers
Cheers good morning John good morning
Hank it's is this your video or mine cuz
it's my camera it's my video but you're
going to edit
it and then upload it on Friday no no no
I don't love this this is going to be
the first ever we're drinking tingling
which is Ting and rum yeah Ting Ting is
like grapefruit soda from Jamaica yeah
which is where we are we're in Jamaica
on vacation and we were thinking what's
the most radical countercultural thing
that two content creators could do in
2023 and that was to go on vacation and
not make content about it yeah we
haven't made a single Tik Tok I took
four pictures and they're all of cats 1
2 3 four there they are which
is hey who's editing
this whoa whoa I thought we were taking
it down in auction 2023 now you're going
to make me put pictures of cats in the
video yeah I'll DM them to you all right
I'll put a picture of like what the
Ocean looks like which I think is even
bigger news than cats they're really
good cats yeah Hank and Katherine will
look away from a beautiful sunset across
the Jamaican Horizon to be like look at
the
kitty no apologies it's great um we've
had an awesome time this is but yeah we
have not collabed at all we've not made
any content instead we've been making a
different kind of content called life
yeah well I'm try also just trying to
it's it's perspective making and also
perspective I just really like John and
Sarah yeah and so does Catherine and
been a good hang s just had a lot of fun
hanging out yeah that's one of the
things that surprises me sometimes is
that we don't fake it for the camera uh
we genuinely get along it's so fun we've
had like two fights since we became
professional
Partners you a lot of them have been
forgotten over over the years I think I
guess we had a fight like 2 weeks ago
but it was just you were being so
annoying I wasn't even like mad at you
about anything you you hadn't slept in
like 48 hours is that I'm going to put
that on a little bit on you or the
situation I felt like you were being a
little Annoying earlier but I was tired
John bet Sarah a million dollars that
this couch swung like a like a little
like a fun outdoor swing I I asked her I
asked her if she wanted to bet a million
dollars and she said no because was so
confident you seemed very confident and
that's part of my trick it does not
swing as it turns out it's a stationary
outside bed but it's still pretty nice
yeah this we have now been going for 2
minutes and 52 seconds and this battery
light is blinking red I mean it's this
is exciting for the viewer and for us
except they actually know when the video
is going to end you should probably just
say Hank will see you on Friday just in
case Hank I'll see you on Friday okay
we'll keep going though okay until all
right I thought this this is going to be
a no cut video and you've now been
making me do the end in the middle in
the middle end you just end if it
doesn't make it you just cut there and
that's the end okay yeah all right all
right I feel like I'm going to have to
put at least three Cuts in this thing
and four cats and some ocean definitely
cats are important the project for
awesome starts on Friday we're extremely
excited about that part of the reason
we've been on vacation is to Center
ourselves get ready calm come to the
project for awesome from a place of lots
of energy because it both takes energy
and gives it uh so it's going to be
intense 48 hour live stream Extravaganza
starts noon on Friday you missed it what
did I miss it's 4 minutes and 1 second
now oh I we're already going to have to
do cuts okay I thought you really going
to try to do a no cut
spectacular well you you once I've got
to put in a picture of a cat Hank I
might as well just spend 4 hours editing
a YouTube video you know what cancel the
good morning Hank it's Tuesday Tuesday
and would you like a chippy buddy oh he
made a chippy buddy y'all he really did
it chippy buddy chippy buddy it's not
chippy buddy it's just chip buddy but it
feels like it should be chippy buddy
it's just mayonnaise bread you didn't
have any brown sauce so I put fish sauce
on it
oh oh God that looks awful it's just
carb on carb on carb it needs more
mayonnaise what do you think of
platypuses I think they're fantastic for
me it's a take it or leave it thing like
if you could kill the last Platypus no
Hank of course I would not kill it's
just like walking slowly toward a
garbage disposal can either save it or
not and you're like dig it or leave it
it's like the trolley problem but if you
flip the switch nothing bad happens
can't believe you're still eating it I
can't believe it's still happening there
was a hair can I identify whose it is
that's that's Sarah Hank do you believe
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
um no no I think it can go either way
yeah sometimes things that don't kill
you make you stronger like exercise I
think it's really uh personto person
situation to situation I don't know
about you but lots of bad things have
happened to me that didn't make me
stronger at all like
labyrinthitis like just made my life
worse for a while no still like a little
bit worse I was thinking of cellulitis
sorry you had a lot of diseases I've had
a lot of iises I'm heavy on the itis
heavy on the itis is going to be the
name of your Memoir man that's great
Hank what are your thoughts on the
upcoming f one
season I think that I think that is a
car thing oh that's impressive I didn't
think you would know that in my head
here's what I have somewhat dependent on
Russian oligarchs to be fair it relies
on dirty money from all over the world
gotcha have you ever heard of the
following names Lewis Hamilton I knew a
guy named Lewis who was actually from a
town called Hamilton he was like a
biking Advocate and indeed leis Hamilton
also enjoys transport wield
transportation have you ever heard of
Max vers stappen Max vers stappen those
like unlike that other guy sounds like
an F1 driver he does I'm just saying if
I heard his name Max veraton or whatever
like I'm like yeah that guy sounds like
an F1 driver all right it's like the guy
who operated on my hand when I got my
attendant yes was named Dr hand I had a
doctor an anesthesiologist Nam doct
sleepy named Dr House oh like House MD
and he's like putting the anesthesia in
and he says I'm Dr house or whatever
ever and I'm like hey do you know that
there's also a
uh and I assume that's why he became an
anesthesiologist he have that joke over
and over and over again you know he's
like the that's other anesthesiologists
have you count back from 10 I have you
tell me that you've seen a show called
house oh please don't you just got it
near my face on purpose I would really
wish Vlog Brothers had smell a vision so
that everybody could be in the boat I'm
in right now they're good chips yeah
yeah no they're really good they're from
a they're from a wood they're local
french fries Hank what are some things
that you do when you don't feel inspired
read always helps though it's hard to
make myself do it what I do is I yell at
myself and I say like you idiot get to
work and that is totally ineffective but
I've but I've been doing it for 40 years
so it's hard it's hard to break the
Habit we have to make a lot of stuff and
I regularly am like it's Thursday I need
to make a video I don't I'm going to
make my video about and having gone from
the place of I think this is a disaster
and it's not going to happen to the next
day there is a video and it's good had
it happen enough times that it doesn't
freak me out as much as it used to I'm
sorry that you didn't get shying my
chippy butt keep making the name of it
worse the name was terrible to start and
it just gets worse I'm glad that we have
a lot of British fans who can feel uh
insulted I'm a big believer in cultural
humility but that is a bad sandwich Hank
I will continue to see you right now I'm
going to go hang out with your son good
morning John what why am I here why not
a dance no dancing oh God no just FYI I
set your chair a little low on purpose
that joke never gets old to me did you I
did I did I have no idea oh no we in the
same place at the same time because it's
our mother's birthday and she loves that
we're spending time just as brothers and
our spouse's favorite thing when we
sneak away we're going to make a video
and play some Spider-Man video games
Hank I know that you've asked the people
of Twitter for some questions for me did
did they deliver John yes have you read
any fanfic of your own books oh yeah
there's a lot of Isaac related Fault in
Our Stars fanfiction which is fun
there's even some people who wrote
versions of the fanfiction that Daisy
writes in Turtles all the way down I saw
that by the way Hank have I told you
that Turtles all the way down is
actually going to be a movie like not F
not for fun but for real I think you're
about to go have a conversation with
someone about it the star of turtles all
the way down Isabella mered whose face
is currently covering Hank's
face you going to do some it's your
video but you've got to you still got to
do that what happens when the Sun dies
well I don't know what happens when the
Sun dies but I I do believe that the
people who love us will miss us my
favorite kand Reef line yeah that's what
happens after you die and that's what
happens when the Sun dies no it's not
how do you keep learning things after
school stops I mean crash course yeah
use crash course there what it's
definitely a way that's one way but in
general don't you think it's about
pursuing inquiry and understanding how
to it's about being curious and knowing
how to chase the Curiosity knowing how
to chase the question that learning of
how to ask the question around the
question is kind of best done by reading
non-fiction I always sort of have a
block and I'm like I don't want to read
a big old book about that and then I do
and I'm like I have so many questions no
it was actually was so interesting
that's my relationship with science
books books of medical history history
books I just get so thrilled by to me
learning is about getting in touch with
that part of you and then being having
the time and the space and the the skill
set to pursue that Curiosity what's your
favorite like thinky podcast where you
like learned stuff you didn't know
before the anthropos scine reviewed oh
my God you literally knew everything in
that podcast it's the only podc where
you knew everything not when I started I
love 99% invisible I feel like I learned
so much from it I learned so much from
Radio Lab from invisibilia there's a
wonderful podcast through line that I
learn a lot from Little St James wants
to know do you have any Elden ring
strength build PV
strategies I don't know what any of
those words mean why do I get shocked by
metal all the time in Vegas why does
that happen there's no air in the water
there's no water in the air there is no
air in the water it's a huge problem
only fish have solved it is that why
when the air is dryer you get shocked
more is that why you get shocked in
Winter cuz the air is dry yeah yeah yeah
yeah you remember when I started a
YouTube channel called all the questions
and the goal was to answer every
question you never think small I was
like we can just record them 50 at a
time you've got to give an exp
you get watch time you do it like the
pronunciation guide where you like have
the video start and then like 15 30
seconds in you're like hor doties
there's an app called how Jay say oh I
know how Jay say my favorite thing is
that he said everything he didn't like
just because people know how to
pronounce it doesn't mean he hasn't said
it right so he's just up in
here good old Jay I was
dancing there's not a lot of words to
start with but butty also in the UK boy
what booty people in the UK what is that
word han it's a sandwich that contains
nothing but bread and french fries so a
chip buddy is a particular kind of Buddy
and any kind of disgusting buttered
sandwich is a buddy we actually have
french fries upstairs we do we're going
to go we're going to go get a chippy
buddy John I'll see you on Tuesday and
right now good morning John it's the
last reunion
video it's question Tuesday we answer
real questions from real ner feds we're
GNA get right to it it's the YouTube
Edition SE yeah who is your favorite OG
YouTuber back in the real early days
Community Channel Natalie tral my 2006
favorite was probably lonely girl 15
yeah my 2006 favorite is probably like
the wine cone oh I loved the wine cone
and Z Frank of course when did you
realize this was going to be your job
it's still not my job I don't get paid
to do this so uh NEP careers on YouTube
tend to be very short like Hank and I
have been on YouTube for 15 years now
and so we've seen how yeah really really
good careers cannot last very long and
the people who stick around tend to be
people who reinvent themselves a lot
which we don't do and US Sam asks what
do you think are the best and worst uh
site functionality changes YouTube has
made over its existence well in 2007 the
site didn't work and people forget about
this but like the site works now it's
very player is very good player
excellent people forget how good the
player is there are a lot of secret hot
keys and that's my favorite ux thing
where like if you know you can do a
bunch of things you can go back a frame
or you can go back 10 seconds frames in
terms of my least favorite feature uhhuh
I think it was better yeah when it was a
five-star system wow well because then
they went to likes and dislikes and now
they got rid of dislikes I think five
stars was the best yeah but I'm old so
of course I think that and also I wrote
about thear was there any time Jason
asks during Brotherhood 2.0 that you
wanted to stop Yes like in March where
it still felt like a really long project
but the hard part for me is always
Imagining the future that gets really
overwhelming right in the present it was
always fun um Jeremiah asks when is the
next X jokes in four minutes coming
that's the first minute of dear and
Jan's for yes that's where I do that now
Jessica asks who got the play button for
Vlog brothers or do you take turns and I
do not know the answer I don't know
where it is I just in the background to
see if I have it I don't think I do I
think it's on the wall at complexly okay
I remember I was on a plane when we hit
1 million subscribers and I remember the
feeling uhhuh it was incredible mhm and
now I never think about it who is your
oldest YouTuber friend Hank ah that yes
I feel like Hank and I are really lucky
that we have each other because if we
did I wouldn't have a peer and now I
have a colleague it's very hard to do
this on your own who understands what
it's like from the inside uh Robin says
I miss video responses do you miss video
responses I miss them now way more than
I missed them when they actually got rid
of them because I feel like they would
do better now some people forget this
like video responses were widely misused
yeah it's really uh easy to forget how
much we know about those days of YouTube
thanks for chatting about it with me a
little bit it's been fun it's been fun
mostly I had a good time I thought you
me the entire 15 years oh no no I meant
the last 12 minutes thank you to
everybody who's been through even a
little bit of it with us and
John I'll see you on Tuesday good
morning Hank I'm still here he's still
here so Hank and I had an idea which was
to look at our tweets from 2011 but
because I'm smart I deleted all my
tweets from 201 11 a long time ago but
instead I guess what we're going to do
is just look at what I tweeted 10 years
ago yeah so these are Hank's piping hot
Frozen cold 10-year-old takes here we go
thank you Portland for an amazing night
I may never wear shoes again oh there's
going to be a lot that I do not have any
idea where they came from well I'll tell
you what the people loved it it got nine
likes this is another tweet that
reflects the sort of 2011 aesthetic of a
quaz I stream of Consciousness Twitter
feed who the hell got potatoes all over
my phone i' have to assume it was me I
am stuck inside of around 20 t-shirts I
literally cannot get out of them by
myself the initial Panic has subsided I
now accept my fate I remember this yeah
I I remember that very specifically yeah
that was a vlog Brothers video uhhuh was
a lot of shirts you put yourself inside
of 20 t-shirts try to like break a
Guinness World Record or something I
wasn't even close so it's just like a
challenge I was not able to get out of
them by myself this is a one even though
it only got three likes just did some
official counting $993 to keep it
$879 to shave it uh-oh keep it made a
comeback oh God like this this huge huge
mistake huge mistake huge mistake it
hadge effect and you still have to deal
with the after effects yeah which is
that the First episodes of Si show and
crash course were both filmed with a
goatee you know what let's bring it up
there it is goodness great ious how did
it happen why did it why was it allowed
to go on why did people donate for that
to remain well the thing is I tweeted
that shavit was winning yeah and that
was the mistake big mistake Tio's cover
fact Jon's name is now as big as the
title which means that he's kind of a
big deal when did that book come out it
came out in January of 2012 this was
October of 2011 so I had just seen the
cover for the first time yeah and I
actually as I remember it there was so
much negative response to the cover you
were trying to find a positive spin on
the cover people did not like the cover
it turned out that the cover did pretty
well turned out it was a good cover all
right Hank we have here a tweet about
Hank Green the Celeb Chaser is there
anybody nearby who could potentially get
me in touch with
Skrillex what 14
likes
why did I want to talk to Skrillex next
next
tweet Katherine and I just broke into
someone's house then we took their dogs
for a walk does everybody else like the
Everyday I'm Shuffling song as much as I
do I don't know if that was like a a
little ironic cuz it was big already or
if it wasn't big already and I was like
on the on the like catching the a wave
wow that's a true snapshot sometimes I
reize that the way we communicate with
each other in the world is being
revolutionized and it is
exciting which it was in 2011 it's still
exciting back then it was exciting in
the way that you feel when you're going
up a roller coaster and now it is
exciting in the way that you feel when
you're going down the roller coaster but
you're actually going further down than
you went up and you're like wait how far
how far down does this go this tweet
only got 15 likes but I really love it
from the research I have done I am
willing to assert that there is no
abominable snowman I think he's totally
Bominable I'm actually going to retweet
it right now Hank I will continue to see
you right now all right every day I'm
shuffling
one I want to retweet that nobody laughs
at their own jokes like Hank Green good
morning John it is Friday good morning
Hank that was very good I'm about to
fall I can do this use your
core so John you uh have been talking to
me about Crown Hill Cemetery for a long
time highest point in Indianapolis
America's greatest Cemetery the most
vice presidents per square mile anywhere
in the US it's true as long as you count
dead ones so here's what we decided to
do I was like let's go Epitaph hunting
yeah and then we will reconvene and
share the best epit and if you have the
money to spare a few extra words onto
your Tombstone I think it adds a lot
yeah even just one bananas I want to
start with this guy here Hank Stan
mollus he died in 2012 and his uh
Tombstone is a tennis net and it says
game set match because that's when it's
over that's when that's when it's all
over is he a tennis player he was not
only a tennis he was a professional
tennis player he owned the magnet
company that designed magnets for the
Apollo mission that were instrumental
magnets to the uh aollo Mission mooning
oh to a mo to a moon arrival to
America's mooning yes heck I'm sure you
recall Neil Armstrong's first words upon
landing on the moon I am mooning let us
Moon we did it Buzz we're mooning what
is that is that your you're you mooning
yeah he's mooning now what is your
understanding of the verb to moon walk
upon the moon oh okay this one was weird
laughter is the best medicine why are
you on this
planet I mean it's very funny and it's
like I don't know man great question I
found a similarly inscrutable one the
sober one is currently on tour
you will always remain in our hearts
forever Sil one is currently on the
first part sounds like an artificial
intelligence is
right John this one on the back in
quotation marks just says I'm all right
I'm all right I'm all right while we're
talking about ones that are lovely he
filled his Niche and accomplished his
task he left the world better than he
found it that's nice I think it's lovely
we've talked about good ones I think we
should talk about some bad ones
beginning with this guy Ebenezer Dumont
criticism is that he's obviously a very
accomplished person he has listed way
too many accomplishments the font gets
too small and so you end up you can't
even read all the things that that he
did you've got to pick a couple things
like Benjamin Harrison who was president
of the United States picked a couple of
things it says lawyer and publicist
which it turns out meant something
different then yeah it seems like a
weird thing to pick out like I was a
lawyer and also I helped people get into
US Weekly back then it meant like uh a a
person concerned with or expert in
issues of the public I am very fond of
the idea that even the things we Etch in
stone are not necessarily etched in
stone I liked this one to live in the
hearts of others is not to
die these days mausoleums cost like what
houses cost they don't do them anymore
very rarely the last one was the Bane
one oh my God the Bane one can we talk
about it it's on the hill where the
fancy people are buried it's a very
normal looking mausoleum
it's got a a nice little walk walk a lot
of space it's open it's very
neoclassical and I've always just walked
past it and thought like that's a
mausoleum Hank Green ever curious walks
up to the edge of the mausoleum and what
is inside is truly astonishing I'm sorry
that I couldn't get better footage of it
than this I and more power to him like
just wh yeah I mean it's such an odd
place because of course it is very
somber and there is a lot of sadness
there but there is also room for that
thank you for taking me there thank you
for showing me around you are becoming a
legitimate tour guide of Crown Hill
maybe that'll be your job eventually oh
gosh someday John I'll see you now bye
good morning HK it'ss Tuesday good
morning John he's here it's a reunion
spectacular oh I feel like you're
getting stronger as you get older uh god
well thanks I feel like there's some
well Hank if you had a chance to rename
Twitter what would you name it here's
the brand okay careful exclamation point
careful careful careful what are your
goto
2021 holiday gifts a nice towel yeah a
good towel is great you know what I
would recommend signed copies of the
anthropos scine reviewed book which are
available with a special Zen written by
me that contains an all new review and
also written by lots of other people at
dftba.com Link in the D all proceeds go
to charity I want to move the camera
further away from us so that we are both
in frame what is the thing about
yourself that you dislike the most let's
switch it around what is the thing about
the other person that you dislike the
most what's one of the ones that people
say in interviews I think John cares too
much yeah I think he just cares too much
he works too passionately yes I would
say that both Hank and I are a little
much oh yeah I mean I have spent a lot
of time wondering like what the inside
of your head is like over the years
because you're the person I've in the
longest it's funny to realize that the
inside of heads are very different even
the other day you tweeted that like you
don't feel guilty for your thoughts M
you sent me a follow-up text to try to
like explain I was worried yeah yeah you
were like I don't want you to think that
I'm like a bad person and I was like no
I don't think you're a bad person I
think you're enlightened you can have a
thought and understand that it's just a
thought that a thought is not an action
right and I would be totally embarrassed
if people knew about the thought but
they don't yeah you understand that they
don't just like a ocean it's ocean of
thoughts yeah but then you pick up one
little drop of water and you're like oh
this thought is very dangerous and weird
and I don't like it and so I'm going to
keep thinking about it and then there
now there are two drops of water and now
there are four and now there are 16 and
now there are 32 and Etc I do that but
with uh sock sales
techniques serious question not related
to question Tuesday do you think you can
take your talent for selling socks which
I would argue is genuinely
unparalleled and apply it to coffee it's
a different challenge can you do it Hank
but I bet I could I love that
self-belief I had a great Book Sales
idea John great for like when when
anthropos reviewed is Whit listed or
whatever Whit listed white labeled white
labeled when the publisher is like we
have too many of these when it is
remaindered my idea is to instead of
signing them yeah um sign $2 bills and
call it a $2 discount oh that's good one
time I was at a book sorting facility
and they were like there's a copy of
your book Paper Town here's the machine
where through an algorithm or whatever
it either gets kicked into this row and
goes back to the warehouse or it goes
down uh this shoot to be pulped in a
machine that like looks like a the
garbage compactor from Star Wars I
wonder what's going to happen with your
book Paper Towns you watched it I
watched it get kicked on to the conveyor
belt and then and then chomped where
they like that's normal and fun yeah
yeah yeah that's what they were like
that's the way the cookie crumbles Hank
what do you want to be when you grow up
oh um I think an author I would love
that I can't guarantee that though
because I I don't know if I can write a
book I know I can write two specific
books yeah I know I can write the books
I've already written I always thought
that once you write a book you know how
to do it you don't I know as little
about how to write the book that I am
currently writing as I knew about how to
write looking for for Alaska 15 years
ago yeah it's so different or actually
18 years ago oh God we have to go Hank
I'll continue to see you right now [__]
you're fine you're doing great we're all
going to die good morning Hank it's
Tuesday oh look it's Hank's book an
absolutely remarkable thing which he
wants you to know is available at fine
bookstores everywhere has been since
2018 Hank today we're doing something
called mindblowers with Hank and John
where we share with each other the most
mind-blowing facts that we know oh okay
okay Hank here's my first fact pi
calculated to the 38th digit is precise
enough to calculate uh assuming that we
knew all the other numbers the size of
the Milky Way galaxy to within a few
centimeters so like we only need to know
pi to the 38th digit but we know pi to
the 31 trillionth digit that's not a
fact about Pi it's a fact about humans
we're amazing yeah I can't get enough of
us I read a few years ago that there are
probably fragments of dinosaur bone on
the moon the asteroid that killed the
dinosaurs probably shed debris as far as
Jupiter another great mind-blowing fact
is that uh some science communicators
figured out that bananas were a really
good system for the scale of radiation
how so they have a little bit of
radiation in them and so like eating one
banana exposes you to some radiation so
you want to know how much R radiation
you get like flying in a jet airplane to
Europe you can do it in bananas now I'm
going to have to Google how many bananas
and airplane flight is to find out if it
was worth it to come here to visit you
here's a mindblower that Hank taught me
before the Big Bang is an incorrect idea
because in addition to creating space as
we Now understand it the Big Bang
created time as we currently understand
it yeah no absolutely to me the
mind-blowing fact is that you can look
up into the sky with a telescope and see
the big bang here's a great one Henry
Rice told me this if if the universe
were infinitely big and infinitely old
the the night sky would be white why
because there would be light from all of
the stars in every direction there would
be no space not taken up by stars
because the universe would be infinitely
big and infinitely
old okay Hank here's one that gets me
for
99.99% of human history you could only
hear music if you were within earshot of
someone who was making it yes and the
idea of an album of record Ed music is
younger than Dr
Pepper we do not know why there is
matter what and we do not know like in
two different ways one we don't know why
there wasn't an equal amount of
antimatter and matter created and so
everything annihilated itself like at
the big bang it just like should have
been like even Steven yeah it big bangs
and then it big mops well and then just
like it like space and time continue to
bang but matter does not according to
our understanding of the universe a
universe without matter is is just as
likely if not more likely than a
universe with matter and then like
separately from that we don't know why
matter exists at all so we don't really
know why I'm here oh definitely not okay
well like like on way more levels than
just those two right like we don't know
why I'm here in the sense that like we
don't know why the atoms that are inside
of me exist yeah it'd be interesting to
look at what makes a fact mind-blowing I
think it's when it makes me feel either
big or small when it recontextualizes
understanding of myself and my place in
the universe yeah like I want to
understand my own emotions because
ultimately I am the most interesting
part of the Universe I would argue that
I
am it's
weird do you not do you not wake up in
the morning and your first thought is of
me and my needs some days when it's a
really bad day yeah I do think well we
are on a little infinitely tiny Speck
yeah on the one hand it's that feeling
of wonderful smallness where which you
would think would be sad but but isn't
but then on the other hand there's the
feeling of like well there might not
have been matter so in that sense I am
quite something this whole thing is
weird thank you for coming to my TED
Talk Hank I'll continue to see you right
now good morning Hank it's Tuesday I
missed you so much that I green screened
myself into your background just
kidding I don't like when you do the
thing where you put your chair up
slightly higher than mine so you appear
taller lower
lower there we go hello welcome to
question Tuesday what is your favorite
Tik Tok sound you can really dance wow
you can really dance Sarah told me
actually she had a dream last night that
you and I were trying to make a Tik Tok
to the wow you can really dance oh no
sound while they were like trying to
like get us to leave to like go do
family stuff what is your favorite essay
in the anthropos reviewed book the first
one that got me that made me cry was the
the the was it is it the the first one
in the book The Liverpool one yeah
You'll Never Walk Alone man it must be
so like enjoyable to uncover that like
there is a depth there oh yeah that even
the people who really enjoy it don't
know about it the thing about
non-fiction that I prefer to fiction is
that in fiction the things that happen
have to make sense and in non-fiction
has to like fit the theme yeah yeah in
non-fiction the things can just be true
and in the case of You'll Never Walk
Alone the true story of the song is so
phenomenally good What would Hank and
John from 10 years ago say if you could
time travel and tell them
everything I think myself from 10 years
ago would be like oh that sounds cool
that's awesome that's that sounds that's
a little scary that
sounds too many
slices too many SLI slices I don't need
another slice that's that's what they
would say yeah how about you I think I'd
say what is
Doge and why do you want me to buy it
and then sell it and then buy it again
and then sell it again at a very
specific schedule how do peppers work
which kind it I think I don't ask the
questions here oh is the less ripe ones
green and the most ripe ones red oh no
no there different varieties different
kinds of Pepper would you rather have
mint flavored gum or fruit flavored gum
mint yeah first off fruit flavored gum
does not taste like any fruit it tastes
like you described fruit to an
artificial intelligence that then ran a
thousand Sim ations of what fruit might
taste like and then was like here's some
fruit flavored gum Hank what's going on
with the crash course coins so yesterday
we just launched this new project the
crash course coins um I have I have them
here in my hand cut to a closeup cut to
close-ups crash course reaches like 70
million students a year and we are
looking to continue to be able to do
that there's a $100 one that will allow
us to reach 2,000 Learners and a $500
one that will allow us to reach 10,000
learners we're only making 500 of those
what kind of inconsequential brotherly
arguments do you get into Hank acted as
if I stole money from his trophies which
he did he would he would roll up the
money into his trophies and then I would
steal it I would definitely steal it and
I bought all kinds of things you're
saying you're saying that I acted as if
a thing that happened happened yeah yeah
yeah but then you didn't contextualize
it properly I used most of the money to
buy baseball cards which you sold
without my permission when we were in
college I believe I believe you I can't
I and like it does seem like a thing
where I would have convinced myself that
that's okay my baseball card collection
on eBay it was so I learned so much
about business and commerce it was very
valuable lesson you use those that I
then paid to found dftba.com right I'm
sure I'm sure if you hadn't sold my
baseball card coach on eBay you never
would have known how e-commerce Works
did you get emotional when you saw each
other in person yes during the pandemic
I have like struggled to feel emotion
when the thing is happening yeah and I
kind of letel feel it later thanks for
coming to our video Hank I will continue
to see you now good morning Hank it's
Tuesday good morning John that's really
not my best work we very nearly had
actual Brothers on a hotel bed HEK it's
question Tuesday the day that we answer
real questions from real nerd Fighters
and you are going to have to figure out
the theme of today's questions I didn't
look okay what in your opinion is the
most beautiful word I like penumbra
for me it's ongoingness I don't like 12
that's a hard one 12 what was the most
foolish thing you did as a child I
remember getting in a lot of trouble for
throwing glass bottles off of our Fort
Hank what do you think is the most
beautiful phenomenon in the anthropos
scene I bet there's a couple colors that
didn't exist until we came around that
are pretty good I was going to say the
understanding of the speed of light
that's good too Hank what is your
all-time favorite foolish Endeavor I
have an answer for this my all-time
favorite foolish Endeavor is a guy named
Tony Hawks hitchhiked around the
circumference of Ireland with a
refrigerator to win a bet and the book
that resulted is as amazing as you would
hope that's a good foolish Endeavor it
um I was just going to say all of
humanity have you gotten the theme of
the video
yet no I didn't yet I didn't get the are
you serious I no you seriously don't
have the theme of the video no I wasn't
paying a ton of attention what was it
favorite word and then there was like
stupidest thing you done
mhm I think everybody out there has the
theme this might get you to the theme
okay what is foolish oh okay I got it
okay finally what is foolish but also
beautiful the the
internet and
also what and porcupine we were like in
lock step the internet Humanity
porcupines I didn't have that one I was
going to go beautiful I was going to go
like heno poppers what is the best
advice you ever got from your kid
sometimes Orin will say feel happy
that's good that's helpful one time one
of my kids said it's just
YouTube are there any old school nerd
fighter isms that have made their way
into your everyday language in the very
first vog Brothers video ever the camera
turns off and you say auto power off why
the still some glitches to work out and
I say auto power off still some glitches
to work out all the time like every time
something goes wrong with the camera 13
years later I'll still be like auto
power off still some glitches to work
out is Humanity worth saving oh yeah yes
I thought about this a bunch actually
right it's sort of what you write about
in your novels yeah I think Super yes
yes in fact I will get into that that
conversation fairly deeply in this book
great I can't wait I'm almost done I
will send it to you probably Monday have
you stayed in any hotel rooms as good as
the one that had that Picasso since 2012
I've never nope not even close we almost
always stay in Courtyard by Marriotts
thank you there's actually a courtyard
in this one which is unusual Hank do you
think that I should go back to sports
Twitter my Twitter account at sports
withth John not regular Twitter I think
you should do what you want to do John
since I left Twitter MH Liverpool
Football Club
have not lost a game in the Premier
League so why would I go
back I'm the one who's making it happen
what's the last movie that made you cry
it was it the last movie I saw which was
Little Women which was very good every
movie makes me cry like I haven't I
haven't seen cats yet but I'm sure it
will make me cry I don't want to see
Cats I
don't um but I support people who do I'm
not here to harsh on your yums if you
like cats whatever that's great God
thank God that somebody likes something
somewhere Hank mhm I will see you I will
continue you know yeah all
[Applause]
right as you can tell from the gray
speckled walls behind me I've once again
found myself in an airport but this
airport is different from most not only
because it's playing smooth jazz but
also because it contains a
Hank the side of my face has been
bruised by the hat that I've been
wearing it's also a little warm in this
airport did your head get too big no my
head's the right size it's your head
that's too big no but like did your head
get bigger and your hat stopped fitting
is there a disease that makes your head
bigger there is Hank thanks for
mentioning it hey Hank what's the
embarrassing story that got cut from the
podcast that's your most embarrassing
story ever I don't think it's that
embarrassing but everybody I tell it to
was like no you can never say that out
loud okay then you just tell it tell it
I'm ready it's time you've you're one of
the people no the time has come no
actually I've decided I'm too
embarrassed I knew it I mean look the
second most embarrassing thing about
Hank is that he faked a British accent
for a full year when he was a teenager
what was your favorite class that you
took in college mine was about the
emergence of Islam in Central Asia which
is a little bit Niche but it was a great
class I liked all my classes except for
physical
chemistry that is not how I felt about
college have either of you ever
considered getting contact lenses I got
contact lenses for a little while when I
was in high school they hurt my eyeballs
I just don't like the way I look without
glasses
I feel like I'm not myself yeah no we're
Total Space Aliens ready
[Music]
mhm the music is making it very hard I
feel like we should be slow dancing
would you ever consider writing a novel
together
yeah I'm surprised that you said yes now
I'm thinking maybe the answer should be
yes yeah cuz there would be really great
spaceships and also great love
stories oh God I don't want want to
write a love story set on a spaceship
can I just have it be a room but then
the room is happens to be in a spaceship
the whole story takes place in a room
yeah like they're in space prison or
something that's the great yeah space
prison love it's what it's called it's
the name of the book it's happening
based on my current writing face look
for it in 2031 did you do you want to
see the text message you sent me where
you were like I have a great idea I did
that was a great idea that was a
million-dollar idea and my feelings are
hurt that you're even going to read the
text messages if it weren't a million
idea a novel that's comprised of a
single 52,000 word YouTube comment that
is a great idea and it's a free idea I'm
sending it out into the world would you
want your Collective portmanto to be
Jank or Han yeah the collective portm
thing is for people who are like in love
and dating like bener William H Macy and
Felicity Huffman are dating they've been
together for like 30 years and their
couple name is filam H muffman what
would be your petronis like a little
baby bear tiny little baby cub little
yeah little cute little cub is really
new he falls over sometimes oh mine
would be a very old Fox like
an missing your inflatable crayon are
you kidding me missing your inflatable
crayon somebody left an inflatable
crayon at the checkpoint and that's
cause for a a full airport alarm 100%
some mom somewhere was like oh thank God
we left that inflatable crayon Han why
does my cat smell like a diseased goat
you should get that checked out why do
you know what a diseased goat smells
smells like 20 years from now what would
you say to someone who wasn't alive
about what now felt
like oh I don't it felt very you know
what it it felt like starting a lot of
sentences but not knowing how to finish
them Hank it's so fun to be on tour with
you and Katherine thanks to everybody
who's been here thanks to the Madison
airport for being so accommodating and
also for their uh really smooth smooth
jazz I will see you on Friday but also
now
let's go eat food hold on we got to do
the thing where I'm I'm a surprise guest
all right that that'll be actually a
good intro just use all of this good
morning John good morning
Hank we're at VidCon from Adobe are you
going to become one of those people who
like wears your sponsors all the time
and you're like I want to shout out
Oakley while I'm here and also thanks to
diet Dr Pepper for providing me with
that key hydration Ashwin at # any cost
# invest iny digestion # menam musel I
actually didn't bring my Metamucil and
it's already a problem don't move I'm
not going to never move again they won't
let me open this all right let's go cuz
that kid peed off the balcony at VidCon
2016 and now they closed all the
balconies that is such a great metaphor
by the way for the internet one person
PE off a balcony and nobody else gets a
balcony ever again so I asked people to
send us questions about our past and
future on YouTube Kathy asks why did you
stop making straight up silly videos I
think what happened is that I felt like
the rest of the internet got pretty good
at being silly but it wasn't as good at
Being Earnest and I was like oh I I I'm
I'm quite Earnest out of everything
you've created Blake asks what piece of
content are you most proud of oh uh
definitely that um tumblr post where it
has me jumping against the wall to prove
that I'm not an octopus it maybe your
most viewed piece of media John if death
is a cube does that mean you have to
meet the face of death six different
times if death is a marble will it win a
marble
not you look very cool speaking of
marbles how did the green ducks do in
the marble Olympics I haven't had the
chance to watch yet I don't want to
spoil this for you like go green ducks
chalon says when you guys retire I
imagine your education channels will
continue but will you let Vlog Brothers
die or is Vlog brother something you
will continue until you are physically
unable well thanks for that I want to
choose to end the channel you you want
to upload a your last video and know
it's your last video instead of just yes
I mean it's interesting to think about
like why are we still doing this it's
been a really long time it has been over
a third of my life Wow and you're old I
like our job like I like I like the
people I work with I like making
educational video like looking super
cool and your Adobe hashtag Create Your
Story sunglasses do I actually look cool
I don't think I look that good for one
thing I got to take off this sticker you
know like obviously we haven't done it
for money for a long time so there are
other reasons we are making stuff and
the main reason is the main reason we
were making stuff in 2007 when there
also wasn't any money involved which is
that we like making stuff with people we
like and we like each other and we
really like the community of nerd Feria
yeah sorry that was overly sincere can
you
go BL you want me to dab don't dab on
camera don't worry a no dab Zone # no
dab Zone pcan pancakes wants us to do
another year of Brotherhood 2.0 style
vlogging maybe the last year that we do
it oh that's a good idea be so hard for
me to stop I think I would I think I
would spiral the other thing is that
it's really good for my mental health to
have the anchor of a Tuesday aside from
everything else there's also that I
don't want to quit let's not quit why
would we quit stop talking about
quitting it's weird Phoenix says I just
ate dinner that's great you two could
switch personalities and lives would you
why are no no no I like my kids I like
Hank's kid but not not as much as I like
my kids our lift driver just asked us if
we were going to see that Chuck green
thing I mean I'm really honored if
people still associate VidCon with Chuck
green I was jealous of your eyewear so
I'm putting on my Cinnamon Toast Crunch
sleep mask I'm going to put on this
fanny pack these are socks I can't see
anything where's the fanny pack I don't
know I also can't see anything I look
like the worst Blues Brother I thought
it was a blanket it's a Cinnamon Toast
Crunch bathroom how did you get this and
I didn't get it I'm super annoyed what
What Hank I'll see you on Tuesday #
winit ashall costs avoid the dab
no good morning Hank it's Tuesday good
morning John oh we're in a pecan Orchard
it's really nice and we're on the side
of the road in this beautiful pecan
Orchard HEK it's question Tuesday the
day that we answer real questions from
real nerd Fighters first question Hank
do you have a favorite hat H available
at dftba.com only for the next 5 days
along with all the other pizzza Miss
gear extra cool if you wear it like this
oh boy I mean that is that is a dad hat
Hank how's the tour been uh so good so
good so good it's really just two so
Goods it's three so Goods so good so
good so good so good Hanks right too
much or not enough I would rather have
too much oh yeah American John how's the
book doing well it's been number one on
the New York Times bestseller list for
three straight weeks so thank you
everybody how does one explain Pizza
John to somebody who doesn't know about
pizza
John I don't I feel like it's not
something you explain it's just
something you accept yeah you're just
like it's the guy who wrote The F in our
star that's all you got to say and then
they're like oh and he's a pizza which
of you is more of a lightweight clearly
me I mean I mean he Hank is the lightest
weight John how sad are you to be
missing out on Saturday at podcon I'm
sorry to miss the first day of podcon
although there's still going to be
plenty of Life Dear hanken John I'll
still be there but I'm missing it
because I'm interviewing former Vice
President Joe Biden so I'm not that sad
because I'm pretty psyched about
interviewing former Vice President Joe
Biden you I think people know who Joe
Biden is you don't have to qualify every
time oh yeah I don't I don't know did I
ever tell you Paul in the sidebar do you
know who Joe Biden is I do feel like you
could say nothing and Uncle Joe would
fill up the time good old Uncle Joe God
what if he knows that we call him Uncle
Joe and he introduces himself he's like
hey John nice to meet you I do not
appreciate being called Uncle Joe on
Vlog Brothers they're going to have to
like prep him right and it's going to be
like so who's this guy who's
interviewing me and they're like well
actually he made a video about you in a
pan Orchard while wearing his own face
on his torso that was my Joe Biden dance
that was just for Joe no one else gets
to enjoy it Hank are hot dog
sandwiches no opinion
whoa so a thing that Hank and I have
been doing on tour is we have decided
that we have too many opinions so every
day Hank and I are abandoning one
opinion I've abandoned my opinion on
whether a hot dog is a sandwich I've
abandoned my opinion on Phil Collins's
music I no longer have an opinion about
it I have abandoned my opinion on other
people's opinions of Emin flavors which
is a big deal for Hank because he was
Hardcore anti- peanut butter M&M so bad
nope but you are allowed to love them
there you go I'm going to abandon one
opinion every day until I find that I am
left with some really core important
opinions hey Hank how would you
summarize the book tour experience in
the form of a
haiku you didn't give any prep for this
you didn't give any prep for this that's
you're not you're not even close
nauseated
bus now I'm drunk again
hanging out with John a
lot birds
fly around
me I don't know if you knew that about
the tour experience every go outside
it's just like well cuz of the nauseated
bus the birds flying bird like in the
cartoon hey Hank where can I get pizza
Miss gear and for how much longer
somebody knows how to get on question
Tuesday this
way no you have to go to dva.com and
it's only available until Friday Happy
Pizza miss everybody Hank I will see you
whenever you get back oh there you are
op PSN someone asked can we get a
discount code for pizza Miss merch and I
decided you know what yeah for the next
24 hours if you use the discount code
Pizza you will get 1% off 1% off of your
purchase at dftba.com it's a great
discount Hank for anything on the whole
site for anything on the whole site w
1% good morning Hank it's Wednesday
guess what we're doing I you know the
pizza cocktail thing we're making some
pizza cocktails we're using my pizza
John shot glass and then this glass from
the hotel because Hank forgot his pizza
John shot glass I did okay Hank first I
need some V8 juice some vodka a
mozzarella stick and uh pepperoni it's a
super modern take on the Bloody Mary I
hate Bloody Mary by the way one of my
least favorite of cocktail like tear it
like this and then put it on the room of
glass the mozzarella stick and the
pepperoni I think are mostly for garnish
but you can stir with the mozzarella
stick as
well that's bad that did not taste good
taseer mozarella T pretty good though
all the stuff you don't want goes in
there boy that looks exactly like
puke all right our next cocktail is
called The Tipsy John Green Hank I need
some Diet Dr Pepper and vodka oh easy
peasy
pink
that's good it is good that's the best
diet prepper I've ever had it's best
vodka I've ever had the old school Vlog
Brothers joke it's equal parts champagne
Dr Pepper and Strawberry Hill but they
didn't have strawberry H so we're going
with Mike's strawberry lemonade here's
to the species continuing into 2018 Boop
small
Pleasures really good amazing oh my God
one of the best Champagnes I've ever had
A++ that's like the best way to have
Diet do pepper the best way to have
mikar lemonade and the best way to have
champagne sorry you'll Excuse me while I
pour myself another one how do you make
oval teen how do you make oval te yes I
don't know Hank our next cocktail is
called the Hank one part Strawberry Hill
which in this case is Mike's Hard
Lemonade one part vodka and one part
oval te because you made an oval te joke
in the previous video So you you're the
reason we're in this problem maybe I
made a mistake beautiful like striations
in John's look how pretty it is show it
with the pizza John out so people know
that there's value in that oh the remote
control cheers to calzones to
calzones not good this is a very good
one it's called keep it simple and it's
just a shot of bubbly water for yourself
a double hey cheers here's the Willis
carrier Willis carrier long may he live
M oh that might be my favorite of the
night Wisconsin hany we are down to our
last drink of the Flying Like a G6 the
guy who created the periodic table also
created vodka he he defined vodka
seriously so yeah he was a Russian and
uh and he created the definition of what
vodka was Hank we got to get to our last
drink of tonight which is it's called
the Vlog Brothers classic okay it's
Strawberry Hill with a peep on top what
flavor do you want do you want a
marshmallow ghosts or do you want spooky
cats Just for future reference peeps
don't have flavor they just have shape
we don't have Strawberry Hill but we
have Mike's Harder strawberry lemonade
if you weren't completely incapacitated
by the 2 and A2 units of alcohol you've
had you would understand the incredible
importance of pitching dftba merch
during we don't have to it's such high
quality stuff people will get it whether
we talk about it or
not oh I mean that was almost my
favorite drink of the
night Hank get a hold of yourself for
God's sakes the winner and the person
who's going to receive all the pizza
Miss merch is the old school Vlog
Brothers joke equal parts Strawberry
Hill champagne and diet Dr Pepper it was
delicious I want to fill up bottles with
it and sell it on the black market I
wouldn't go that far Hank thank you for
being here get some rest and I will see
you tomorrow
good morning Hank it's Monday it's pizz
Miss I only get to say good morning Hank
it's Monday once a year on pizz Miss Hi
how are you I'm good pizza Miss is a
two-e period where Hank and I make
videos back and forth to each other
every weekday to celebrate Brotherhood
and affection and pizza and e-commerce
hey Hank uhhuh do you know why I haven't
shaved since the book came out is it a
luck thing nope AFC Wimbledon no that's
the business I know it is great thank
you for
noticing all right we're in the
dftba.com warehouse which means that we
are with the pizz Miss stuff right now
that is on sale only for the next 2
weeks Hank let's do a pizzamas unboxing
video it's a
haul
[Laughter]
oh what is it it's a pizza a sun shade
for your car oh God the great thing
about this also is that it serves as a
theft deterrent because nobody wants to
Rob this car the pizza Miss Hat it's
really good so like subtle we're not
trying to kind of throw it in your face
does it look good with the mustache and
pizz shirt so every year we have a bunch
of different designers do a Pizzo design
for us so their take on Pizza John this
is Lily Nas this is chibi John oh my
goodness it's the first time I've seen
it it's so good oh man oh the little
mustache oh my gosh Evan Palmer did this
one it's amazing oh my goodness and then
we've got this one drippy pizza
face boy swerve oh boy thank you swer a
big deal oh God Hank this is the best
your pizza ever these are Joey chews all
these again available at db.com only for
2 weeks managing this project is one of
my favorite things to do every year
because I just get to tell designers to
be weird and then the weirder it is the
happier I am yeah you like this one o
who do you think did this one m I don't
know who B Cafe I also feel like this is
a gift that you give to me every year
it's the weirdest time of the year
because we make daily videos for no
reason other than to Hawk weird Pizza
John mer
all year round and I'm very grateful I'm
getting ready for this oh my God it's my
face as a piece of pizza It's So Meta I
love that everybody's worked the
mustache in one way or another he it's
almost like my mustache is actually
awesome and people like
it everyone leave we'll have a poll on
the side of the video tell us if you
like John's mustache and want it to stay
I would say tell us that you like John's
mustache and want it to stay that pajama
top a pajama top it's so comfy see
doesn't that look great I feel ready for
s professionally styled that actually I
have to say is your P look good thank
you it's incred I have been working out
as you know uh that is incredibly
comfortable oh it's like a warm hug and
then there's this amazing sweatshirt
which was designed by Beth radol it's so
cozy my kids are finally going to think
I'm cool we're just at the cusp of the
beginning of the fidget spinner fan too
which is great thinking this is a high
quality fidget spinner actually so his
little faces on there this is my last
pizza John surprise of 2017 I just want
to say thanks to you and everybody at DF
va.com for making this already a great
pizza Miss it's a pizza John shot glass
for your real pizza parties for when you
go Pizza Hardy oh
God it's great I mean it's definitely a
pizza John shot glass and this marks the
first time I don't know nerd F ter is
getting
older I guess it's okay yeah you can
drink whatever you want out of it that's
true take a shot of ovaline there's also
a lapel pin pictured because we don't
have it in stock yet and John and I just
spent a lot of time signing these and
then John spilled Coca-Cola on a bunch
of them yep s about that uh those will
be discounted but all the profits from
uh the posters uh will go to the
National Alliance for mental illness
Nami if you come up with a pizza John
cocktail for US Virgin and alcoholic put
in the comments we're going to select a
a top one that we like the most and
we're going to send all the pizza stuff
to you Hank and I will drink all of the
suggestions I think that's and then we
will make a decision I think this was a
a terrible improvisation Hank I'll
continue to see you right now but also
I'll see you tomorrow okay and the next
day all right we just did our first
warm-up show Hank how did it go bad no
it went it went all right okay uh you
could kind of tell that we'd never
rehearsed well this was a rehearsal and
I was somewhat surprised when I found
out there were going to be 150 people
there they were very nice though were
very nice especially Olivia who told me
all the words to my songs Hank forgot
the words to every single one of his
songs but fortunately there was a young
woman named Olivia in the front row who
had all of Hank's songs memorized so
everything worked out better than
expected I wouldn't actually say better
than expected
I would say differently from expected it
worked out just fine is this the final
version of the book it is what does it
look like with the dust cover off oh me
there's a secret there's a
secret there's a secret yeah I'm not
going to show you it's pretty cool right
that's great yeah that was designed by
people in nerd figh areia why didn't you
tell me about that we could have made
merch from it oh my God we have merch
from it it's called Turtles all the way
down it's available in bookstores
everywhere okay Hank I'm going to ask
you some questions from our audience
that we didn't get to answer during the
show if 2016 was a giant dumpster fire
what is a visual representation of 2017
is it just like what's left after a
dumpster fire 2017 the year of burnt
garbage do you listen to music while
you're writing your books you this will
surprise you Hank but I do only the
mountain goats how does it feel to have
Hank be a published author I'm so
psyched I'm so happy I'm so proud of
Hank John yes if I was cast in a movie
adaptation of your book who would I play
I mean that seems unlikely on a lot of
levels can be the Tara that's actually
not a bad call show me your best
tuara I just got a neck cramp God that's
one of the most disturbing things I've
ever
seen I'm going to put up a real toara
let's go back to back is it a good
impression or not you be the judge but
it has to have like some lines it
definitely does not have lines the whole
point of the two atar is that it is a
cold I'm the
tutar
hey oh man I'm a living fossil again
Turtles all the way down is out now and
you can go to the subreddit there is a
link below if you want to talk about
spoilers please don't talk about them in
comments thank you thank you for reading
dftba Hank I will continue to see you
right now all right Henry what should be
the topic of my question Tuesday video
Pokemon Alice what should my question
Tuesday video be about monkey Turtle
monkey turtles good morning hick it's
Tuesday it's question Tuesday the day
that I answer real questions from real
nerd Fighters about Pokémon and monkey
Turtles oh and look it's a reunion video
we're all here together in the desert I
don't know what monkey Turtles are I
also didn't know what a monkey turtle
was so I asked Alice and she said it's a
monkey that turns into a turtle right
yeah right for why oh I asked her that
and she said for protection then I asked
Alice how big monkey Turtles were and
she said 100 big it's big actually well
or not it's true it depends on if it's
millimeters you need to learn units
talking to Alice is like talking to a
not very good AI she's like a bad chat
bot yeah she said to me uncle Hank I got
this new water bottle and I said is it
better than your old water bottle and
she said it's pink the other's purple
like it's like I asked you a question
you answered a different question but
you kind of were on the same topic she's
also like a chatbot in that a lot of
times if you ask her a question she'll
say I don't want to talk about that what
is your favorite Pokémon and why is it
Charizard it's not Charizard it's
Snorlax because he's cute and large and
Powerful mine is Andrew Andrew yeah have
you have you seen Andrew Pokémon is he a
monkey Turtle no he's just a guy plays
guitar what Pokemon could best keep a
steady job oh probably
Andrew put it in your head Charizard
managing like a Wendy's and if like the
grill breaks he's just on all the
burgers oh my God he can cook the
burgers oh wow what is the most
underrated Pokémon oh I think the most
underrated Pokémon is surfing Pikachu
I'm going to go with like the the wiggle
puffed jiggly puff or uh Spike ladder
Spike ladder that's a real one is it you
ask Henry what he wants to be when he
grows up he says inventor and then he
pauses and says of Pokemon John yes how
can I be the very best like no one ever
was come on if you had to permanently
dye your hair a non-natural color what
would it be uh silver ooh well you're
getting there already I know I'm on my
way when I was in college I thought to
myself I want to have a job when when I
turn 40 I can get a mohawk mhm and how I
do hey welcome to crash course
biochemistry it's me your cool teacher
Hank with the 40-year-old moh doesn't
all value derive from
humans no I just want to say for the
record Hank is not taller than I am it's
just that he is standing on a rock I was
downhill Hank what is your favorite
adjective to throw in when you want to
spice up a sentence spicy I don't like
that at all what do you think of that
three-point shot Hank spicy I don't want
to be like my friends will all be like
yeah Hank the one who says spicy all the
time oh yeah Hank spicy green they call
him oh shoot who would win in a fight
between a monkey turtle and a turtle
monkey oh definitely a monkey Turtle cuz
it could turn into a turtle for
protection what is your favorite type of
plate oh uh for me it's the the kind
that the Earth's crust is on ooh I mean
those are good sometimes you're at a
really fancy restaurant and there's a
plate on the table before the food comes
out and then they take that plate away
yes and I'm like what was that why was
that plate there yeah just in case
explain it to me it's a just in case
plate would you rather have C3PO in your
house or
R2-D2 R2D2 because like I like whenever
I hang out with you I kind of feel like
I do have C3PO in my house that's true
heck What Pokemon do you think looks the
most like
you I don't know either but I'm excited
to find out from our viewers isn't Mr
mime the only one that walks on two feet
um I mean or like it's vaguely human
shaped I don't know of a greater insult
than saying that someone looks like Mr
mime we're going to go keep walking so
goodbye friends bye I'll see you now you
want to see our uh our incredibly
sophisticated tripod by the way it's
Hank's wallet and two
rocks good morning Hank it's Tuesday
wait what is this background am I on a
green screen am I in Montana yes you are
it's Hank it's a reunion video it's
happening Hank is making his triumphant
but temporary return to vlog Brothers
hello hello I might make another video
this week about VidCon you're so bad at
paternity leave okay Hank I got some
question Tuesday questions from nerd
Fighters for you first how is Orin doing
Orin is your son he's good he's good
he's a good baby so cute he's very cute
oh it's almost unbearable I think he may
have smiled at me this morning really
maybe he might have just been pooping
Hank why is there no sequel to The Fault
in Our
Stars oh it would have been I think
maybe not the happiest book I also don't
really know how it could have happened
happened but believe me people in
Hollywood did make suggestions favorite
Disney movie go is go a Disney movie I
thought that that was way too dark to be
a Disney movie I think it was rated R I
liked um the new one that Linn Manuel
Miranda wrote the songs for you know ly
manw Miranda wrote a song for the new
Star Wars
movie unfortunately we don't um have the
ability to clear the rights to that song
but on the upside that was not a good
enough version yeah uh nobody knows what
I was singing for copyright to come into
play what is the most surprising Frozen
that wasn't the question what is the
most surprising thing about having a
baby the noise of the
poops like literally surprising like
like I'll be like within the first day
of Orin being home uh he he pooped with
his diaper off while I was changing it
MH oh that's a rookie error I'm a rookie
I know Henry pooped on me so many times
Alice pooped on me never because I would
go in with like seven diapers I'd be
wearing like a diaper suit of armor but
I went ahead and tried to catch it with
my hand nope I was like switch glasses
every time we do this I'm like yours are
dirty yeah that's how I like to see the
world through smudged lenses this eye is
pretty much exactly the
same oh yeah wow the left eye is the
exact same it's almost like we're
brothers if you could take one book to a
desert island what book would it be I've
been thinking a lot about leave it there
so no one could ever read it again the
fountain here is my idea it's a book
where if you read it forwards all the
it's just the collected works of
Shakespeare so it's Rich it's
complicated it's beautiful and then if
you read it backwards um like the back
sides of the pages are a survival guide
for how to live on a desert island I was
going to go with the the king killer
Trilogy by Patrick rothos even though
the last book isn't out yet cuz I I if I
was going to get stuck in a desert
island I better have that third book I
was going to say how terrible would
would it be you know what would happen
though because Pat rothus is such a
great guy um you wouldn't get to leave
the desert island but an airplane would
fly over drop the third book when it
comes out and just wave goodbye to you
yeah like a bottle of water and you'd be
like that's all I needed thanks Hank do
you have any self-care advice no I I
have lots but self-care bunny has better
self-care advice yeah selfcare bunny is
just here to remind you to be nice to
yourself yeah what did we learn from
Nathan Zed's video you are a good
burrito not the best burrito you don't
have to be the best okay stop putting so
much pressure on yourself you're a
really good burrito there's no best
burrito that's right there's only
different kinds of good burritos that's
true actually yeah that's true on many
levels all right Hank write an
autobiography in five words I guess mine
would probably be um is this mole a
concern I wrote he made stuff with
John God that's so nice Hank thanks for
taking time away from your baby to make
a question Tuesday video thank Cath
I will see you right now all right by
why are we what when did this become a
thing what what do you know Alice does
that she thumbs up yeah whenever you're
like hey Alice smile she doesn't smile
but she's
like great good morning John it is
Tuesday nope Friday good morning Hank
it's a reunion video Hi how are you
how's it
we we both kind of look tan well I think
it's cuz of the bad lighting so a very
special question Tuesday John it's been
9 years that we've been making Vlog
Brothers video I wanted to do a question
Tuesday in which we tell people things
they still don't know about us I asked
Twitter and here are some of the
questions that I received who had more
girlfriends in elementary through High
School me yes I had more girlfriends in
elementary school though I will say I
killed it in elementary school no you
didn't I had long-term relationships in
elementary school that's right I was
just like hop hop hop hop hop I held so
many hands did you when you were kids
did you know what you wanted to be when
you grew up I thought that I wanted to
be an oceanographer but but it turns out
that I don't like uh boats I did want to
be a writer when I was a kid but I never
thought that it was a realistic job I
thought it was like wanting to be an
astronaut or something what is the
pettiest thing you still argue about we
did have an argument yesterday about
which uh part of the human body would
take the longest to eat no I feel like
the argument was about which part of the
human body would make the largest uh
contiguous steak it's all petty until
you're a cannibal and then it's suddenly
very very real Glen asks does John cast
movies no who has bigger ears asks Sarah
H I don't know my ears are this big my
ears are this big let's measure with The
Goonies like right here okay I made a
little Mark all right there we go I have
the bigger
ears but I'm older yeah they keep
growing they keep getting bigger Henry
is right behind the camera and uh I just
asked him if the video was funny and he
said no so I'm concerned so Han can you
do something funny it's
like he
laughs all right the video is funny
again bubble baths soothing relaxation
or boiling Cesspool oh boiling Cesspool
no no no no we're about to have the
pettiest argument we've ever had Babs
are wonderful it feels like like putting
my entire body on the every other part
of my body anley asks nerd fighter Emoji
there's there's one that I I use is it
this one yeah it's the lady who's going
like this Hank what is your 20year goal
oh when I'm 55 I want to still have a
colon how is Dave Green fine he's doing
good whenever I'm like how you doing
Dave he's just like the l t d m he does
say that it's weird I don't think it's
that weird I think it's cool I keep
thinking it's FTD which is the flower
delivery service have you ever seen each
other
poop Henry is finally laughing again
probably when he Hank was like 3 months
old but it's been a while rapid fire
what's your favorite musical Hamilton
what's your favorite poem uh the second
coming by wb8 uh what book have you
reread more than any other actually
probably Hatchet by Gary Paulson if you
go back to my childhood last question
Hank what do you think think of as your
biggest accomplishment when you do that
it makes Shadow animals on my body is
this your biggest accomplishment right
now this making a terrible duck that
kisses me on the cheek my biggest
professional accomplishment is Vlog
Brothers uh my biggest personal
accomplishment is uh behind the camera
you picked Henry no I mean I'm also very
proud of Vlog Brothers of course but
among that uh in there I think my
greatest accomplishment is having made
the internet's most viewed video of a
goat giving birth is a thing that I
did that's incredible no one can take
that away from me I'll see you on Friday
Tuesday so bad at days I know I know
it's going to be a problem for our whole
lives good morning Hank it's
Wednesday it's Pizza we've just come
from the uh save the children gay I met
Jennifer Garner that was weird and I but
she seemed cool uh stood nearby Olivia
wild it could be a Gala or a Gala do you
want to answer some questions that
people just sent John Green what is your
opinion on lamps I am opposed to them I
Love Lamp debate over the best kind of
chocolate white milk or dark I don't
know if this is going to be a debate but
I actually have a very strong opinion so
let's just do this 1 2 3 1 2 3 dark oh
thank God because we were about to not
be brothers anymore will there ever be
dear Hank and John Merch that's what the
world is missing is dear Hank and John
Merch merch you know what kind of merch
we do have pizza John Merch available
now only for a couple more days at
dftba.com Pizza Miss merch it's like
suits but mostly t-shirts actually you
know what I was wearing underneath the
whole time the save the children Gala he
likes to keep me close to his heart John
yeah do your best impression of your
favorite dinosaur we don't know what
dinosaurs sounded
like it's
true
might be it might be I'm glad you made
it at least you made a noise that was a
dioicus my favorite dinosaur but we
don't know if that's what they sound
like we don't know we have no way of
knowing we have no way of
knowing maybe they just were like
sounded like humans they were just
like like that dog from that that thing
on
Tumblr rosiana took away my Tumblr
password so I don't know what's
happening on Tumblr anymore I got sounds
funny it's why did you take away my
Tumblr password there are so many lovely
things happening Nicole's question is
what are your holiday traditions say
what we're thankful for oh our mom
always puts tremendous pressure on
there's a great deal of pressure to come
up with like a new thing that we're
thankful for so if I say like I'm
thankful for my kids mom will always say
no no no no no you said that in
2011 and I'll have to think of something
new that I'm thankful
and I'm 38 you know 38 years of having
to be grateful yeah you you got like
take individual
Foods this year I'm thankful for green
beans God I'm so grateful for
cranberries where would we be without
them as a species yeah roughly yeah
exactly the same place but where would
cranberries be they would be dead uh
like 40% of species which we've
eliminated in The Last 500 years go
team actually no that was not not an
appropriate high five well I I mean
99.9% of species that have existed no
longer exist right but uh usually not so
rapidly we've eliminated more in the
last 400 years than uh than in the
previous million yeah yeah we're roughly
on par with an asteroid we are killing
it oh literally Hank can you please
describe the meaning of life from the
perspective of a chicken
hey how did uh you and John meet your
wives I met my wife she lived across a
uh a a
desert a continent hallway an
ocean from my from my dorm room all
right room service is here we have to go
Hank thank you for being awesome I like
your time by the way you're welcome I
got it at Banana Republic dftba I will
see you right now also tomorrow good
morning Hank it's Tuesday it's question
Tuesday the day that I answer real
questions from real nerd fighters let's
go uhoh it's a wild Hank and he's goto
bombing me yesterday we were out to
dinner and I made a dumb face in a
photograph and everybody at the table
decided it was goto bombing yeah was
like photo bombing but he looked like a
goat speaking of goats our first
question is would you rather fight one
Johns sized goat or three goat sized
John's I'd rather fight one John sized
goat you are crafty making you a goat
would make you easier to fight there are
definitely goats bigger than you I I
don't think so I think that I might be
bigger than any goat by way Siri are
there goats bigger than my
brother I'm not sure I understand I
don't understand either let's go to the
next question what are your thoughts on
goats in
sweaters Oh you mean like uh where you
have a sweater and there's a goat on it
no goats in sweaters a sweater wearing a
goat I mean a goat wearing a sweater
sweater wearing a goat is a fantastic
idea you know goats have rectangular
pupils by the way I did know that oh you
know why they're like horizontal
rectangles which probably means that
they're trying to look out in more
multiple I want to know what that's like
I bet the Oculus Rift could like could
show me what it's like to be a goat do
you want another question yes let's do
another question how many llamas is one
goat worth can I just pause real quick I
can ask why all the questions are about
goats the thing is I just asked for
questions there just happen to be a
bunch about goats I also ask them to ask
questions about goats oh I see your
Tweet goat questions preferred who can
do the best impression of a goat you
want to go first no I want to go not at
all I'm happy to lose if Hank will
try that was so
bad that's what they sound like you've
never even met a goat you know what they
sound like that was perfect that's not
true I PK I made The Internet's number
one video about goat mating don't tell
me I've never seen a goat I've seen a
goat do it and they make that noise nope
this is a question that I don't think
you'll find particularly difficult Hank
would you rather have a goat eat your
ear or would you rather eat a goat's ear
how was that even the question it's like
the old question would you rather uh eat
five pine cones or poop one like as
unpleasant as it would be to eat five
pine cones obviously that's the better
option I'd rather eat a goat here than
any other part of a goat because you
could take the goat's ear and it would
be fine not fine how would you feel if
you were earless I noticed that you and
I have different iPhone password so if
you want to ask another question you're
going to have to log in John where does
the word goat come from oh I know that
actually it comes from Old English what
is your favorite breed of goat brand
brand of goat breed I'm going to go with
the American mountain goat I was going
to say the mountain goats too which kind
of mountain goat though oh John darnal
probably if you had seven goats between
you what would you name them I would
like to have four of the goats that's
all that matters to me I would like to
make sure that if we have seven goats
between us I have have the four and you
have the three how about alternatively
you have all seven wait I've rethought
my answer I would like to give you the
seven goats all right I took another
guess of your iPhone password I still
didn't get it go toorn or unigoat yeah
so we're talking about two different
animals the go toorn is a goat with a
unicorn horn the unigoat is a unicorn
with a goat head or as I like to call it
a horse and I'm going to go with the
unigoat here is a non-oat question for
you H what really gets your
goat
[Laughter]
when awful people succeed hey thank you
so much for doing question Tuesday happy
birthday is your birthday yesterday
everybody say happy birthday to that guy
uh I will see you on Friday and now okay
and we have to go cuz we're out of tape
so good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm
actually at a mini golf course I wish
you were here but you're busy like
interviewing the president or whatever
oh wait I'm in Florida where this
happens it's question Tuesday the day
that we answer real questions from real
nerd Fighters while also playing mini
golf are you nervous about interviewing
the president of the United States
thanks for bringing it up are you yes
I'm trying to golf but is it going to
affect your golfing it absolutely is
apparently oh oh oh oh that was terrible
how do you look so much taller than me
it must be because there's something
wrong with the ground anyway what's your
favorite flightless bird you're my
favorite brother HEK just got a hole in
one but I insisted that he tapped it
twice because I don't want to get too
far behind and I'm the big brother and
that's how we compete I may not be
better than you Hank but I am able to
change the rules Midstream are you
behind me what are you nothing there's a
ton of waterfalls in this joint if your
last name were any other color what
would it be oh Shar
Tru uh I would go with blue which I
think is a kind of chartreuse the next
question is uh will you try on each
other's glasses and I think we should do
that and Putt Putt ooh thanks
prescription it's actually pretty close
to mine I feel fairly comfortable yours
are just mostly dirty oh my God John I
don't clean my glasses very often but
that's just disgusting can he perform
under the pressure of wearing his
brother's glasses it's ain't green it's
ain't
Green Oh no there it is
yes oh oh come on give me that bounce
that was a good bounce between the two
of us who was weirder in high school oh
I don't know me I feel like me you had
all those friends who's at rhyming I
don't know but I have pretty good
timing sorry I was trying to think of a
a rhyme for timing I didn't get there
diming
climbing climbing CL took me a minute
hang might be better who's your favorite
member of One Direction let's go with
the police officer guy oh I like the
construction worker you know they're all
good though I love that song
yeah it's F to stay y m c a a what
should win the Oscar for Best Picture
I'm going to go with the Fon or Stars
John not nominated um I'm going to you
look like the tifos clouds right now I
know it's all marketing never not
marketing so I'm going to go with
Whiplash or Selma I thought both of
those were excellent Hank how do you
feel about koalas they poop in their
sleep is that true can you play the
ukulele no yes I can play like two
chords I can't play it at all and what's
your favorite type of hummus uh chickpea
I didn't know there were types of It's
the final hole and we are tied oh it's
tense very tense 18 tank is
significantly closer than I am for the
tie
no oh oh no how does it feel to be less
good than me I'll see you on Friday good
morning John it's Friday in fact it is
Black Friday today the darkest Friday of
the year the blackest deepest dark so
ominous everything is 20% off at
dftba.com through Monday I think that is
is great news it's bad for us it's kind
of bad for us we're crazy I've you never
seen an advertisement for DA's guns in
Indianapolis no I don't live in
Indianapolis he sells guns and at the
end of the commercial he says I don't
want to make any money I just love to
sell guns it's basically that's how I
feel about hoodies I'm glad you don't
feel that way about guns let's start the
video over I think that was all gold
okay Black Friday is the day that
happens after Thanksgiving Thanksgiving
is the day that we say what we're
thankful for so we thought today we
would share some of the things that
we're thankful for I am thankful that to
Death Around The World Is decreasing at
astonishing Pace uh that we're we're
maybe only like 30 or 40 years away from
the vast majority of poor countries
being middle- inome countries those was
a different direction I was going to go
for the video I was thinking more like
I'm thankful that farts sound funny
because otherwise they'd just be farts
and it would just be stinky but with the
funny sound they're awesome I'm also
really grateful for nerd fighta uh for
like the chance to be part of a
community that's committed to doing good
and also having a lot of fun I'm
thankful for like human hair cuz I think
it's like I think it's pretty and
functional I'm thankful for people who
work in customer support oh you know I'm
so thankful for everyone who works in
retail today I have worked uh a Black
Friday or two in my life and it is not
easy I'm really grateful that there's
this young generation of people who are
committed activists and working hard to
decrease World suck on lots of fronts in
their communities I think that's really
exciting I am grateful for all things
that you are grateful for I'm also
grateful that my dog is cool with uh me
being the person who decides when and
where she poops like I would not put up
with that you know what else I'm
grateful for what what what I'm grateful
uh that when I show up in Missoula
Montana with no winter clothes because
I've been uh in North Carolina that uh I
happen to own part of a warehouse that
sells hoodies I could just wear myself
in infinite hoodies right you could go
from small all the way to extra extra
large and you could wear real ically I
could go from large all the way to extra
extra large here's what here's a serious
one here's a serious one I am thankful
that the earth's core is partially
liquid allowing for currents in
conductive materials that produce the
Earth's electromagnetic field which
allows us to go outside in the daytime
without dying is that really true yeah
I'm thankful for that that's that sounds
like a huge win I'm also grateful that
humans landed a thing on a comet this is
so much harder than it sounds it sounds
incredibly hard there's a comet it's
like and we're like I know what we'll do
we'll we'll we'll shoot a slingshot and
it'll hit the comment you know what that
reminds me of yeah the miracle of AFC
wimbledon's journey to League 2 I gave
one of these to Henry and you know what
he said when I put it on him what he
said I'm going to grow into
this there's a lot of things to be
thankful for I want to know what you're
thankful for nerd fitan yeah I want to
know a serious thing you're thankful for
and a silly thing you're thankful for I
have to go sign posters now I don't have
the normalist brain and nothing makes my
brain feel
calmer and happier than signing over and
over and over again it brings me great
joy nerd Fighters thank you for allowing
me to sign so many things in the last
year I hope to be able to keep it up for
the rest of my life that is weird John I
will see you on Friday good morning John
good morning Hank where are oh it's Ford
awesome we must be at the dftba.com
warehouse
whoa where's the camera camera it's
question Tuesday to it's it's it's it's
it's question Tuesday the that we answer
it's question Tuesday the day that we
answer real I'm going to leave all of
those in way I know you will it's
question Tuesday the day that we answer
real questions from real nerd Fighters
it's Friday you sure you don't want to
upload this on my day I'm sure I've just
asked on Twitter if people have any
questions for us John would you like to
answer some questions for people yes
that's how question Tuesday and Friday
Jessica would like to know what were
your first cars my first car was a 1991
Volvo 240 named Arlo that was my first
car too I actually uh after Arlo got the
same car car again but uh White and
smelled more like vomit Hank how after
so long have you guys not gotten tired
of each other oh I'm so tired of you my
question is how after all this time have
you guys not gotten tired of us hey John
yes Evelyn would like to know how do you
find a nerd fighter at your University
one of my favorite ways is to wear some
kind of nerd fighter clothing because
that tends to attract them lots of
colleges now have nerd fighter clubs and
if you don't have a nerd fighter Club at
your University you should start you can
start one Michaela asks who is playing
Margo in the Paper Towns movie Hank uh I
am yes we have been begging Hank There
is no other Margot Roth Spielman that's
what we've been saying it's not a
passion project for Hank it's I'm really
not interested in the project itself
purely Financial I'm the Nick Cage of
John Green movies I'll do any John Green
movie as long as you pay me enough poor
Nick Cage hopefully he doesn't watch I
am a huge Nick Cage fan actually this
wood is fake chher Walkin no that was
Nick Cage
from how about you sing the answer to
the next question yes hey John yes Beth
would like to know will she be able to
buy one of those posters you signed yes
is that how you sing we are at the
warehouse right now because John's been
signing posters all day and I've just
been watching him by the way dftba.com
Link in the D we do or just go to
dftba.com you can just type it just five
letters Hannah asks any advice on
strengthening relationships between
siblings make a video blog together I am
a big believer actually in shared
projects like Hank and I are a lot
closer because we do stuff together I
think that goes for most relationships
Henry and I were just making Legos and
it's so fun father son things he he
wasn't really doing anything right you
made Legos and and he was like go Dad do
it and then he would be like that's the
bad guy and I'd be like I don't know I
mean aren't villains complicated isn't
you know we don't know that person's
backstory we need to learn to imagine
them complexly and Henry would say he's
really bad I have a question tell me
some more cute stuff Henry says I will
tell you one more thing we're
emphasizing learning how like knowledge
is power Henry said to Sarah the other
day you know what's a good kind of
learning and Sarah said what and Henry
said learning how to turn on the
TV how does Henry feel about me is he a
fan of Hank yeah no he said uh right
before I left to come out here he said
i' would like you to give a message to
uncle Hank and Auntie
Katherine I'm glad well I'm glad that
that message got passed off it was
literally the last thing he said to me
before I left and I was waiting you know
I was waiting like I love them I miss
them I can't wait to see
them he's probably watched my videos and
he knows that that's how I talk John yes
thank you for doing question Tuesday
with me it has been my pleasure I'll see
you on Tuesday but also now I think they
can see us a little bit I don't think
they can see us they're thirsty for
Augustus Waters John is that what it
said yeah that's a funny pun cuz he
Waters yeah it's an important it's an
important metaphor in the book good
morning hick it's Tuesday it's actually
Monday we're on our way to the F Our
Stars movie premiere it's very exciting
the collaboration between the two of us
and the community that's emerged from it
means more to me than anything else in
my professional life and before we go do
this crazy thing I just want to say
thank you you're welcome also thank you
that's what I was waiting for the mutual
thank
[Applause]
you hold on I have to video Vlog really
quickly instead of a red carpet we have
a tifos blue carpet how awesome is that
so might be sign for some people who'
lined up to produce of the premiere and
then said hi to a lot more people who
had okay Cloud posters by which time my
brain was slightly fried okay Hank I
have successfully signed a bunch of uh
posters and everything not skin that's
my rule anything that's not skin and I
am back on the magic tifos blue carpet
so HEK currently across from me are like
a large wall of
photographers uh that's hence all the
the flashes but uh I need to tell you
that the fallar Stars movie is coming
out on Friday this Friday like the day
after the day after tomorrow unless you
go to the Night Before Our Stars in
which case it's coming out the day after
tomorrow if you want to see it on
Thursday at least in some cities that is
still possible you can go to the fall
Nars movie.com and get tickets Link in
the doooo I am sweating through my
berbery shirt which is only increasing
my already sizable anxiety oh you look
so cute then that will shut up for our
Today Show live chat there are people
from The Today Show talking to me inside
of my ear and then came the live CH with
our astonishingly beautiful and talented
Hazel Shady by the time that was over
things were starting to get quite
crowded I met Indie 500 winner Ryan
Hunter Ray then things got even more
crowded and I kind of lost my ability to
even I don't know I don't know what to
say I don't have I don't have a I don't
have a talking part took a selfie with
Mike bigli and then stood on the carpet
with my brilliant and lovely wife just a
few feet away from shayene and Laura D
and then I got to meet spelling the co-
Champion an sunu Joo unquestionably the
highlight of my my evening okay Hank I
just did all of those press interviews
and now I'm going to go into the movie
look look look look look look that's the
movie well Hank they didn't let me film
inside the theater so greetings from
Tuesday where my view of Manhattan is
not half bad Hank the premiere was just
absolutely amazing laughing and crying
with 1200 people and I'm so glad that
you were sitting there two seats away
from me so like before I say anything
else I just want to establish that I'm
not getting paid for the movie like I
got paid for the rights a long time ago
but I don't get a percentage of ticket
sales or anything and I don't have to
talk about it and if I didn't like it
believe me you'd know but in fact I love
the movie I think it's amazingly
faithful to the book and powerful and
funny and moving HEK the people who made
this movie cared about the story and
they care about each other and you can
really see that last night we all got to
be together one last time which was sad
in a way but it was also very exciting
because it means that soon in fact very
soon everyone will get to see the movie
thanks to all of nerd fit ter for being
part of this process with me read the
book first and Hank I will see you on
Friday when the fall nerd start movie
will be out in theaters everywhere I
doing Hank well so I kind of you know it
was a great Premiere that we have but
you know okay Hank it's the beach a
couple of nerds at the beach we're
actually quite far away from the ocean
cuz there's sharks in there Henry's very
nervous about orcas he keeps being like
isn't Orca going to eat me and I'm like
well not if you're 8 in in the water
good morning John good morning Hank it's
Friday it is Friday H how your hot dog
legs The Infernal Day star is shining
its radiation down upon us I can feel it
giving me cancer light is the visible
sign of the invisible light that's TS
Elliott it's lovely but it it doesn't
mean anything to me when I ask Henry
what light is he always says in his cute
little four-year-old voice it's the
visible sign of the invisible light I
find question Friday the day that we
answer real questions from real nerd
Fighters took our laptop down to the
beach cuz that's how we roll am I on the
screen I'm a little worried that I'm
worri it's a really wide lens Mela wants
to know what is the art assignment going
to premere first the ignment comes out
late February subscribe Link in the
dooblydoo she also wants to know who the
f is Hank oh you weren't prepared for
this I'm never ready Han is the second
largest ocean on earth I don't even know
which one that is that's this one oh no
I think this is the golf but whatever if
you two are fighting and your only
weapons were the objects to your left
how would you use them and who would win
you have a chair that are you I could
just beat you with you you're ha
yourself I just have to
say computer sand Hank's computer
because there's nothing that would upset
him more he would Panic Danny wants to
know how come Dave Green is never in the
video who's Dave the third unsuccessful
brother Dave has been made up by a
Tumblr how did this happen and I didn't
even know about it suddenly I have an
imaginary brother Amy wants to know why
is love so hard what is love H me that
was really not even close people on the
beach are looking at as funny by the way
the people on the beach they think that
we're crazy on the be they think crazy
should always be a little bit of work
because it matters yeah that's true
anyway there's all different kinds of
love there's all different kinds of
farts this is a really good YouTube
video we should we should do this we
should do this more often in comments
tell me all the different kinds of farts
no in comments tell us about Dave
Green just I need that no I need that
John we need that for the rest of the
video so so go get some
glue beautiful
Wendy wants to know which of you has the
worst glasses prescription I don't know
let's take a Switcheroo here definitely
me yeah definitely you wow wait till
you're old I am on acid right now well
yours is very sharp but none of the
things are lining up your left eye is
almost identical to my left eye your
right eye is yeah the right eye super
weird who looks better do I look like a
naughty Professor who looks better than
the other's glasses is that is that a
thing naughty Professor think so I think
you made that up it's uh what is it it's
nutty a Nutty Professor that's what you
were thinking oh I wanted to ask if you
could tell me anything about the Fault
in Our Stars
trailer it will come out soon in the
next few weeks and um yes I have seen it
I thought it was truly excellent I hope
other people like it too I'm very
nervous for everyone to see it but
hopefully soon John thanks for being on
a question video with me oh no thanks
and taking me here to Florida where I
probably got a sunburn just in the last
20 minutes I have sunscreen on I didn't
do that best wishes you need to wrap up
this video I need to go because I I may
actually not survive this uh I'll see
you on
Tuesday how's it
going oh
boy this is a very small ocean you put
me
[Music]
[Applause]
in
I don't think
though good morning John good morning
heck it's Friday question Friday the day
that we answer real questions from real
nerd fighters let's get right to it how
many times have you read the vault in
Our Stars have I I don't know I mean how
many times I read the finished book yeah
the the one that's out in hard cover
yeah that one zero why would I read it
there's lots of other books that other
people wrote that I could read that I
don't remember how many times you read
it twice I read it once before it came
out and once after it came out thanks
for reading it twice what's your
favorite book series at the moment my
favorite book series is always going to
be Harry Potter I like diverging a lot
though which one of you would win in an
arm wrestling match it's got to make for
a bad
video I am going to
lose I mean I could have kept going but
I was laughing so hard yeah uhhuh I won
with my wit did you Hank ever cry to one
of Jon's books yes I looked at it and I
cried to it I also have cried to one of
John's books if you got to give each
other a catch phrases what would they be
imagine complexly yours would actually
be fart fart fart how do you like your
eggs I like
them inside of a biscuit can you please
show us some family photos from when you
two were younger it's funny that you
should ask cuz we're in the room that
has the the photo album I don't know if
I want people to see this that's pretty
cute you're giving me a little bear hug
which one of you is hotter we'll have to
have a pole like we're not objectively
able to perfect that's just what I've
always needed is a pole to determine
whether hotter than my brother asks
dance
Montage you have pizza on Thanksgiving
no we have normal Thanksgiving maybe
someday we'll have turkey Pizza favorite
kind of pie pumpkin pumpkin also it's a
problem because there's only one pumpkin
pie is there this Thanksgiving almost
like The Hunger Games in that one of us
is going to be hungry and the other of
us is going to be dead if John was a
turkey and he was the last turkey on
Earth would you eat him for Thanksgiving
no I mean are there other Foods
available could I have a ham but also if
John were a turkey I probably wouldn't
think very highly of you I'm just amused
by the idea that anyone no matter who
the turkey was would eat the last turkey
on Earth Thanksgiving there's only one
turkey left and it is Thanksgiving it's
like when we found the last IB built
woodpecker and it's be like well who's
going to get to eat this did you do
drawings of one another yeah I did
mine it's Sparkle pen paper what do you
think um yeah I've always wanted a
hankor fish earring I drew Hank as well
um I drew him as a beaver playing the
guitar what's the worst kind of candy I
think the worst kind of candy is
probably a candy none of us ever heard
of because the person who created it was
like well that clearly is poo one time
uh I went to a contemporary art
performance at which the artist who was
Chinese handed out hard candy that
tasted like crabs hat was very bad candy
this person just says bad jokes I'd tell
you a physics joke but you'd probably we
find it boring but you know jokes about
Dorian Gray they never get old is
dftba.com doing anything for Black
Friday are we heck yes there is $3
shipping on all orders no matter how
much you order you will get it for just
$3 shipping even International what if
you have friends and family who looking
for Christmas presents for you maybe
there's something you want to let them
know about how do you make a really good
project for awesome video the KE do a
good project for awesome video is not
just like sitting in front of a camera
and talking about why a charity is
important to you but actually showing it
at work and also consider the fact that
you're basically pitching a charity you
have to let people know why this is
important why it's a big deal why it's
important to you personally yeah the
best project for awesome videos are also
videos that the Charities themselves can
then use in their own Outreach to their
donors we love it when that happens and
we hope that it happens a lot this year
have y'all always been really close no I
mean we've always liked each other
though thank you for watching best
wishes dftba John I'll see you on
Tuesday bye
good morning heck it's Saturday August
3rd 2013 which means that it's Esther
day the day that in memory of our great
friend Esther we say I love you not to
the people we're romantically involved
with which is easy enough but to the
people it's sometimes harder to say I
love you to friends and family
so I love you
Hank I love you
too thanks buddy so for those of you who
don't know Esther Earl was a nerd
fighter that we met at the first leag
who we met who we met who we met that we
met yeah who so for those of you who
don't know Esther Earl was a nerd
fighter who we met in I almost did it
again so for those of you who don't know
Esther Earl was a nerd fighter
that that's just how we talk now no it's
not I no I refuse to accept the
proliferation of that when one means who
Esther Earl was a nerd fighter we met at
leakycon in 2009 in Boston where you
really played your first like major
concert uh-huh yeah I sold my first CDs
ever and look at you now still selling
CDs out of the back of your trunk Esther
was a dear friend to us and a really
important nerd fighter she died in 2010
when she was just 16 but we remember her
on this day and every day by trying to
spread her message of love what a great
thing to say when asked what you want
people to do I know in your memory I
know I said to Esther uh we're going to
do this holiday for you it's going to be
called yesterday it's going to be on
your birthday as long as we make Vlog
Brothers videos what do you want it to
be about and that's what you wanted it
to be about she wanted it to be about
love between family and friends so a
Valentine's Day for the rest of love and
I think that's pretty awesome so uh
Esther we miss you nerd Fighters happy
Esther day thank you for being awesome
Hank I love you soak it up you won't
hear it again for 365 days love you too
best wishes good morning John good
morning Hank it's Friday question
Tuesday the day that we answer real
questions from real nerd Fighters are
there any foods that je wish were more
readily available in the US no we've got
all the major Foods here my major one is
paprika Pringles oh you know what I will
say my wife is a huge fan of Hot Nuts
Sarah will plan trips to Mexico and then
she will come home with like 400 lb of
Hot Nuts and then when you're Crossing
through customs do you have any food and
she's like no I mean I don't think of
Hot Nuts as food exactly we have this
beautiful house and he chose the single
corner of the house that is covered in
flies and when I when I mentioned this
to him he was like but I already set it
up here hi I'm a big F oh thanks man hi
our next door neighbor likes our work I
just saw you guys oh that's so cool well
you'll see this again next week that's
going to make it in I want to ask he
another be you okay there I don't like
bees that's all Henry has nightmares
about is bees he'll have a nightmare
I'll be like what you dream about he'll
just say bees good it's a healthy
healthy fear now that filming the Fon
Our Stars in Pittsburgh has started it
hasn't it doesn't start until August
26th will you be coming to Amsterdam
people seem to think that the movie is
being made by me I am just the author of
a book however I think it's going to be
a very good movie are you missing a
tooth yeah I am missing a tooth thanks
for asking I had like really terrible
chronic pain ever since before
Brotherhood 2.0 finally they had to
remove it and do a very complicated and
painful surgery fortunately it does not
hurt anymore has Alice done a nerd
fighter salute yet Alice is 1 month old
she has not made any intentional
gestures of any kind yet she's more
like yeah Henry read in a bar Bear's
book that sometimes baby sisters Bop you
on the nose so he's always like getting
his nose right down next to her arm and
waiting and then and then sometimes
she'll just involuntarily and but he did
she did it she bought me on the nose
that's the answer to the question what's
the most adorable story you have ever
Hank what is your favorite game of all
time the Game of Thrones I knew it how
do I stop feeling like I'm not doing
anything with my life there was this guy
who is now in prison his name is Larry
Langford and he was the mayor of my uh
quasi hometown of Birmingham Alabama and
when he ran for mayor his motto was
let's do something and it turns out that
just doing something is a terrible
terrible idea you don't need to focus on
doing something you need to focus on
doing good things even like very little
good things like doing nice favors for
people you like or something I like that
do you know how dirty your glasses
are oh man what is something surprising
you've learned today uh uh yeah I
learned that Hank likes to set up the
camera in places that are covered in
flies they tickle no I did learn
something today I learned that the whole
Chinese Monopoly on world silk trade
ended when two guys two monks smuggled
like seven silk worms or something out
of China and took them to the Byzantine
Empire which like completely rewrote
history hey how do you feel about
cucumbers uh they give me gas yeah for
me they're just like a step on the way
to a pickle which I hate it's an unru
pickle I don't love it but I certainly
like it better than a pickle would you
ever consider writing a book with a pen
name it's a good question haven't I
oh I think so what's your biggest pet
peeve oh God freaking flies if time Trav
were possible where would you go and why
to the present because antibiotics and
when John will you be back from
fraternity leave not this next Tuesday
when you will see my secret sister Moren
although she might be me but the
following Tuesday I think it is July
30th we look forward to seeing you then
I look forward to seeing you guys
too I'll see you on July 30th and now oh
my God July 30th is like a day from
VidCon morning John I have very much
enjoyed our family vacation here in
sunny steamy Florida all of the people
and the scenery and this squirrel just
got to talk a little bit while this
squirrel is extremely ad what it's oh my
god of course one of the best things
about any trip like this is hanging out
with you and so here's some footage of
That So Yesterday Hank and I discovered
this new game table topics it's not
actually a game they did not sponsor us
no in fact that's why we don't do
product placement is so that you can
know that like the corporate Behemoth
that is table topics is not responsible
for today's video they also table topics
uh is actually owned by Exxon Mobile is
it really delicious Exxon Mobile Oil
good to the last drum I'm practicing
trying to uh right we got to get good at
this pitch Man Diet Dr Pepper tastes
just as bad as regular Dr Pepper or Dr
Pepper 10 it's not for women it's for
apparently misogynist table topics wants
to know do you live more in the past the
present or the future I live entirely in
the present like people do is that a
question intended to sus out time Lords
um where they'll be like I've been
caught what quality do you think is most
important in marriage and end
marriage what what quality do I think is
most important in ending marriage I
don't know cheating what a depressing
question in marriage Mutual generosity
oh that's very sweet it's true John
what's your dream job oh I have this
crazy fantasy where I get to make video
blogs with my brother and write novels I
mean I have my dream job what about you
same I'm I'm saying except for well but
you have like a million jobs your dream
job is to have all the jobs all the jobs
congratulations you've done it also that
is going to be GIF I'll just get out and
then you just do an all the my belly's
still in my belly that's good cuz it'll
repeat it'll just be youque oh that is
going to be great that's going to be the
GIF what one question would you ask a
psychic how they live with themselves
knowing that their profession is a lie
if it was a proven real psychic I'd be
like tell me the stock market that's a
very sophisticated Financial question
Hank tell me the stock market it's not
even a question it's just a statement
tell me the stock market is a sentence
that ends with a period it's not it's a
fragment of a sentence I guess it would
end more with semicolon or something
John if money were No Object what kind
of party would you throw and wear if
money were No Object I wouldn't throw a
party I would I would throw VidCon even
better I like to be by myself only my
family would no I had a new I have a new
answer okay I would throw a party on
Mars if were No Object here let me ask
you a few Hank if you could be a famous
athlete who would you be this is going
to challenge Hank's ability to Name an
athlete Harry Potter is a he's a pretty
good quidd player he never went pro no
he had other things to do what's the
most significant problem facing the
world farts Henry what is the most
significant problem facing the world
today Hank thinks it's farts is it the
the lack of naps I heard a garage truck
you heard a garbage truck I didn't Hank
if you owned a boat what would you
choose to name it the dark time bad wolf
Hank which piece of land would you wish
to have preserved forever well forever
is an incorrect concept can I preserve
it from the explosion of the sun Hank
what do you miss about childhood Dexter
my feret this was a stuffed fret for the
record what remains undone that you have
wanted to get yet done for years for
years yeah for me it's lipo the
elimination of
death I've been meaning to get to that
Hank what one goal do you hope to
accomplish this year I hope this year to
put an end to all suffering I would like
to do a couple cool projects with nerd
Feria so I see that we work on somewhat
different scales thank thanks for
playing table topics with me I will see
you on right
now good morning he it's Tuesday and
here I am in beautiful Florida and here
I am in beautiful Florida what it's a
reunion video never gets
old it never does get old I still find
this
funny I don't know if they do ah it's
very hot hotot hot H hot so Hank and I
are at a family reunion in Seaside
Florida the world capital of teenagers
who don't know who we are what's it like
well it's been like this
[Music]
basically
save my I got these for Henry but they
were too
big hi John what are you reading and
Demon
nerd yeah I did
it you kill the piggies kill the piggies
and you got one whole star so Hank we're
here in Northern Florida and yes I'm
wearing an inner tube that just sticks
to my body because you know my belly is
too big you don't need a bigger
tube it's all the tube you need yeah
it's just like the internet how is it
just like the internet we always want
bigger tubes you know in these thoughts
from places videos I always try to draw
out some tortured metaphor but that's
the worst one yet
yet noodle
attack do
not do not shake your hair this close to
the camera Justin
Bieber it burns doesn't it burn Burns it
burns open
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
Hank you're the younger brother but your
marriage continues to be an inspiration
to me I'll see you on Friday neck pillow
good morning John oh God please it's
Friday oh God I had four hours of sleep
last night all I want you to do is
record a very quiet video it's a simple
request
we are now in Arizona Oh wait we're
going across the river we are now in
California we're actually still in
Arizona we are now now we're in
California we are at the Jesus Christ's
Lord Travel Center you are wearing a
neck pillow I'm wearing my neck pillow
[Music]
still yes there's a little something on
your face Catherine it's the bun of
[Music]
sin
you're annoying you're annoying why are
you still in this
[Music]
car John I'm here today with number one
New York Times bestselling author of The
Fault in Our Stars John Green hi Hank
I'm so tired I don't want to do
this how does it feel to be number one I
mean it's ridiculous I love the fight
areia so much I mean I would like to
take credit for it but it is it has
nothing to do with me it is kind of cool
that you could have written like a
really horrible book I would have
pre-ordered it and then they would have
got it and be like oh my God this is but
instead you wrote an amazing book love
Grossman in Time Magazine said that you
were damn near genius near well how does
that feel near to be near to genius how
does that feel John I don't know you
tell me as John says in the shows my
greatest accomplishment is being your
brother that's my favorite joke in the
show I love it yeah that and the fact
that almost every night you get shocked
instead of me you're very empathic as
you said last time I was nervous I said
empathic when I meant empathetic um I
also am empathic though what word am I
thinking of um moist you right idea I'm
so you totally right moist he's always
thinking of moist what do you do uh when
you're backstage before a show to get to
get ready um I mostly just sit and watch
you play the same Chameleon Circuit song
over and over and over again
it's I'm very nervous and that's one of
the only things that makes me not
nervous well you know what what would
make me less nervous as if you were
practicing the songs you are going to
play
oh oh the glory of it all our interview
is nearing its end because John has a
hamburger thanks for interviewing me any
final words for the the people of my
audience I hope you guys like the fall
ner stars and thanks for being
awesome
John I'll see you when you wake
[Music]
up in case you're wondering how we spend
the moments before we go on stage get
any purchase on it for some reason it's
disgusting I want to end this oh come on
this is this is there good morning K
it's Tuesday so funny story last last
night the tour to nerd fighting was in
Houston we had a great time and after we
got done signing it was like midnight
and we went to the hotel and they told
us that they had accidentally sold our
rooms and they were very sorry I was
pretty cranky because I really wanted to
go to bed but then we had to go to a
different hotel and walking into the
other Hotel I could tell it was kind of
nice and the guy behind the counter was
like we've reserved one of our best
rooms for you and I was like whatever I
just want to go to oh my God armoir more
like arome I mean he this place is
literally bigger than my house I'm not
even sure that I can sit in all the
shares the beachy gring Engler fish
never has to find the mate they are
always there together when it's time to
procreate see one dark light a young the
female on her side and then slowly he
becomes a sperm producing
parasite and if we could say he lives it
all he lives until she dies and until
that day he literally never Lees your
side yeah you can't HTE the night if you
live your whole life without light you
can't hate the dish you've only
ever we just noticed this is an actual
Picasso print it's pretty unbelievable
there's like there's not even nailed
down I love the things in this hotel are
not nailed down you could just take it
there's a certificate of authenticity
are you serious yeah oh seated woman
author Pablo
Picasso Hank you're holding a Picasso
while eating Pringles
[Music]
firston what you're retiring and
becoming a professional art Thief No
More tour to nerd fighting for
you this is really easy I never thought
art thevery would be so easy all of
which goes to show you Hank that
sometimes disasters can turn out arome
I'll see you on Friday and by Friday I
mean right now cuz you're holding the
camera good morning Hank it is Wednesday
I'm not really in a mood to make a
proper video here's my uncle is bringing
us the hours oh thanks Uncle Mike that's
very sweet uh however we are going to
play a game of word association today
and then you're going to continue the
game in comments I'm going to start now
lemon pie
mering
mushroom what pizza corn dog uh hot dogs
Doxon uh pooping the
Nintendo Sonic the
Hedgehog uh Mario um Luigi Princess
Catherine oh
oh
sweet uh
peppermint um uh
minty um Mitt
Romney
um politician George Bush rich
people Mountain
Brook that's where we are right now
um country clubs
golf
clubs um
Disco
Balls back to golf back to golf and
disco it's just beautiful just beautiful
disco golf balls disco golf ball Loop
yes somebody right now is is making
disco golf balls on tum they should be
selling those on Etsy right now yeah
they will be don't worry buy dftba.com
now available for pre-order disco golf
ball not really not really but you can
get a pizza John shirt um basket um
weaving um
underwater uh
swimming uh
scuba um acronyms that are actually a
lot that's not a word acronyms there you
go
initialism dfba awesome um Hank a a
George Washington is What Hank reminds
me of I remind myself of George
Washington I don't know if you've ever
known I'm a really good General
obelisks ah
phus it's just all balls and fuses today
here where am I supposed to go from phus
what is that supposed to make me think
of um Greek or possibly
Latin
Socrates I mean he is either Greek or
Latin I know from I know from Crash
Course you will soon find out my friend
in episode three of Crash Course um
Socrates makes me think of Hemlock uh
makes me think of pine makes me think of
sap turpentine uh makes me think of that
turpentine smell that's not word a word
that turpentine smell
marble um
Venice
Italy
corruption berlus
scone sex with 17-year-old
girls Al not a word also also not a
word not a word did you ever see the
headline of The Economist but syia
brison and it just said the headline on
the cover was the man who screwed an
entire
country so uh we're going to stop there
and you're going to start at Sylvio
beris scone hey CH dog the doggy so the
the job now is that in comments you the
nerd Fighters will continue our game of
word association say hi to
Chief best wishes good morning John it's
Wednesday chair Wars you say it's
Wednesday it's question Wednesday the
day that I answer real questions from
real nerd Fighters number one what was
your biggest childhood argument I think
that you lying is the problem where you
where something would happen you would
lie and I would get blamed because you
were a better a liar than I was you're
still a much better liar than I am I'm a
novelist it's like my job how come you
guys never come to Ireland or even
mention it um mentioned done would you
rather have a unicorn or a pegasus a
pegasus obviously no yes it has wings
but if you had a unicorn you could kill
it you could kill the Pegasus too if you
wanted to you can ride a unicorn it's
like it's just a freaking horse it's
like would you rather have a horse or a
flying horse is it possible that the
giant squid of anger and the starlock
from Star Wars share an evolutionary
link no it's not because that happened
in a galaxy far far away and there's no
way to transmit genetic material between
galaxies it's also a long time ago right
that's not that's not as big of a
problem it's more the far far away why
does the internet love bacon so much
because bacon is delicious yeah bacon is
good for me did you ever see those uh
those those anti piry ads that are like
you wouldn't download bacon and I'm like
yes I would possible is that is that a
thing we can download
bacon does it come out of my
printer what's your favorite thing about
each other I like like this part totally
creepy you just inspired a a very
unfortunate generation of fanfiction
writers I think there's going to be a
Facebook fan page for this part what's
up I was giving them some of that part
oh so that they could make it make their
screen found something up on my ceiling
I look that why you have Kermit up there
he's just you know my household God I
mean when I have that's where I have
Padre Pio I have a Roman Catholic saint
and you have Kermit I figured ponre piia
was a soccer
player just assumed have you seen the
new modernized version of Sherlock
Holmes are we talking about the
Cumberbatch one or the the Downey junor
one because the Cumberbatch The
Cumberbatch one two thumbs up yes the
Downey Jr one one thumb yeah like see we
don't don't disagree arm wrestling match
arm wrestling match one two three oh my
God I just got we speed
up I give up I give up a do you guys go
back and watch your old videos that
implies that we've ever watched an old
video I never watched you never watch
brother 2.0 I've never seen the show I
really enjoy watching the old videos
particularly your old videos when I
watch my old videos I'm pretty hard on
myself it's funny because I like to
watch my old videos too I like that guy
so funny oh my God why do you do the
things you do wouldn't it be easier to
just play games all day what is the
point of doing things in
general that's it what is the point of
doing things in general there is no
reason to do things there's no like
Cosmic mandate to do stuff I feel bad
for that person because I've struggled
with that a lot in fact I wrote a novel
about it called The Fault in Our Stars
it's available at a link below all
copies will be signed since there isn't
as you said a cosmic mandate to do
things you know there isn't a cosmic
mandate to make stuff and the world
probably won't be any different as a
result of the stuff that you make or do
I think it's human nature I think that
we have a human nature to like to do
stuff and interact with people and and
to make the world better for each other
I think that we like doing that yeah
making stuff is very fulfill in and of
itself in a way it's making a garden bed
or if it's making I mean even you know
video games are set up to do that
they're set up to satisfy that need
right uh but they can also become kind
of insular right no I mean they're set
up to satisfy that need in a very
shallow way we love making awesome stuff
with awesome people that's what we've
always loved and we feel very lucky to
be part of a community where that stuff
happens I'm going to turn that right
there into a song are you I'm going to
Songify is it going to be called making
awesome stuff with awesome people oh
you're going to Songify me I'm going to
sing on key for once I can't ask I do
not have that technology John thank you
for doing my first question Tuesday ever
with me it's been a privilege and I will
see you right now I will continue to see
you stop looking at me good morning hi
it's Monday using the magical power of
green screens I have transported myself
to your home office in Missoula Montana
to show you something that has been
annoying the crap out of me let's go to
the tape you're making a nice video blog
it's funny everybody's laughing there
there enhance there that thing oh it's
so annoying HEK it's glattus she has to
go she's annoying me if only this
weren't a green screen oh wait it's
not goodbye gladus
uh-oh The Illustrated guide to free hugs
just broke it's a breaker everything is
fine that's like my favorite thing
nothing is broken look a
tank ow wow that was unnecessary this a
slidey chare you didn't change the
poster oh sorry I can fix that bam done
this is I mean it's just it's it's a bit
obnoxious is it is that is that to4
I don't know what happens if you go to
that link so I flew all the way to
Montana so I could be in a hank games
video Hank and John play FIFA 11 poorly
very badly man oh when you get to the
penalty kicks that's the second episode
uh yeah stay tuned for tomorrow when you
will see us miss 19 consecutive
penalties um but we played uh perhaps
the worst match that Liverpool and
Arsenal have ever played yes hold on a
second heck
you can watch it right there at
youtube.com/ game you should make that a
clickable link there's also a link in
the dup we do and also in the future I'm
going to be making more Hank Games
videos with Hank which I'm really
excited about because uh I'm really bad
at video games but I'm really passionate
about them it's the same way I felt
about skateboarding when I was 10
another thing I have a punishment um and
I can't do the sandwich punishment
because do you want to show them your
scars not really
okay you just have to trust me that I
was lately removed from my
gallbladder really your gallbladder got
the worst part of that deal that's true
I wrote a ha coup for the occasion
actually would you like to hear it yes
please stupid gallbladder not performing
properly I will kill you
now yeah so my gallad was taken out
which means I can't really do the
sandwich punishment so if you could
suggest a different punishment for me I
would appreciate it and Hank will pick
one in other news we do have a
punishment for Hank so in addition to
Bringing myself and my family to Montana
I also brought one box full of sheets
from the faar Stars which is 7,400
sheets and that is 5% of the total and
I'm going to hanklerfish all of them
ankler fish I'm going to ankler fish
them I'm going to ride an angler fish on
each one of those pieces of we you'll
have a 5% chance of getting a
hanklerfish f in Our
Stars it's a
ver I made up a word and I verbed it I
just verbed verb so a hanor fish is is
an angler fish drawn by a Hank uhhuh
There are other Hanks that can make hler
fish so like if Hank Williams II were to
draw me an angler fish that would be a
Handler fish also be a Handler fish it
would probably be better than mine too
so I had to bring all these copies of
the faar stars because I can't take a
week off from signing right he has to
sign them anyways he has he had to bring
them to sign them uh yeah just in case
you don't know by the way everybody who
pre-orders the fallar Stars uh will get
a signed book second all pre-ordered
copies will be signed and 5% will be
fish all right uh we've got to go to
breakfast nerd Fighters don't forget to
be awesome best wishes don't talk about
my shirt or I'll put Forks in you
where's that from it's from really old
Vlog Brothers video I mean I ning Master
Tom made this we have so many inside
jokes that I don't even get it's been a
long it's been a long time don't talk to
me about my t-shirt or I will put Forks
in you that's a great t-shirt actually I
know we should make that should be a
thing well I kind of like me having the
only
one all right uh goodbye goodbye Hank
I'll see you when I turn off the camera
okay good morning Hank it's Wednesday as
you can tell from the gray speckled wall
behind me I'm in an airport I also had a
colonoscopy yesterday and for lack of a
better word I'm still feeling kind of
crappy so good news people who haven't
yet read the first six chapters of The
Great Gatsby you have an extension until
Monday okay hold on I got to get on a
plane and now I'm at Hogwarts Hank there
are a lot of nerd Fighters downstairs at
leakycon 2011 right now and I feel kind
of bad because they all want to take
pictures and I want to take pictures too
but I have this crippling social anxiety
disorder that makes it impossible for me
to do that kind of thing or to hug
strangers or whatever and I feel I just
I feel guilty in other news Hank you
know that album you've been working on
for a year and a half Ellen Hard Castle
which you named after a nerd fighter who
won a project for awesome raffle anyway
Hank I don't know when it comes out but
I'm really excited well it comes out
today tank hi tank so Ellen heart Castle
is out today yes it is it's available
now and I've got a big box of them
downstairs that I have not looked at yet
congratulations it has awesome cover art
which you're looking at now instead of
Hank's face sorry Hank face so yesterday
we were talking about how uh you know
I'm signing every pre-ordered copy of
the fault Our Stars and I thought that
wasn't enough so I have decided that
instead of doing that for Ellen Hard
Castle I'm going to let you say whatever
you want me to say in a video you are
such a brother like I have a good idea
and then you have to have a better idea
every person who buys a physical copy of
Ellen Hard Castle you are going to be
able to send me a 10-word script for a
video and I'm going to film that video
and then put it onto YouTube it's unfair
I mean I thought I'm going to make
thousands of 10-word videos I was doing
such There are rules I it cannot be
profane it has to be in English and it
has to make sense oh look what those
people are doing is something I would
never do so if you want your own Vlog
Brothers video with Hank Green saying 10
words of your choosing as long as
they're not profane and they make sense
you can just buy a copy of Ellen Hard
Castle and then you'll get an email with
instructions about how to proceed dftba
Ellen Hard Castle or possibly not so I
think it may be dfba Hardcastle
I don't know how awesome is it that you
named that album after a nerd fighter
who donated the project for awesome and
her name happened to be Ellen Hard
Castle anything else there are good
songs on Ellen Hard Castle all right the
music yeah it's good it's good it has
such hits as Phineas Gage and strange
charm the best song ever written about
corks admittedly low bar but it exceeds
it by a lot other hits include shake a
booty which you probably haven't heard
yet but it's one of my favorite songs
ever and there's lots of songs that you
you haven't heard and there's other song
Catherine what are the other
songs we had Catherine hiding in the
bathroom like fery paradox fery paradox
fery paradox the best song ever written
about the fery
Paradox it's true it's true it to no I
completely agree I mean you dominate you
know little known scientific phenomena
songs about I want that to be on my next
H green t-shirt Han green dominating
little known scientific phenomena comma
songs about
I have to go to rehearsal now
dftba Hank I will see you as soon as I
turn off this video good morning John
it's Friday good morning Hank it is
indeed Friday yes that was a poor high
five poor today's video comes to you in
three parts Part One an announcement
part two a challenge and part three
another announcement that is different
from the first Announcement Part One an
announcement the 2010 project for
awesome aome is happening it's on you
might remember in 2007 when John and I
kind of realized that nerd FIA had
become a pretty big deal and we wanted
to do something with the power that nerd
Feria wields we decided to take over
YouTube and for one day YouTube would
not be about kittens on roombas or about
giraffe love it would be about charity
and now for three years straight we've
been doing this very successfully and
it's been getting bigger and bigger
every year this year it's going to be
the biggest it has ever been by there's
going to be a huge epic live show out of
Los Angeles we just got off the phone
with YouTube so YouTube is basically
giving us the same kind of treatment
that like Conan O'Brien and the
president gets where they're doing a
4our live stream on YouTube so there's
going to be this big live show but
there'll also be sorry ah but there's
also going to be traditional project for
awesome stuff which means that hopefully
all of you will upload Amazing Project
for awesome videos on December 17th the
thing to do is to show us Charities you
care about in action and I know that
this might sound weird but it might
involve you getting out of your chair
you might have to leave your bedroom and
that's not something either Hank or I
enjoy and we are sympathetic to the fact
that it's no fun for you but if it makes
for a better project for awesome video
it therefore makes for a better universe
and so get out there so we're giving you
some lead time this time you have three
weeks before December 17th to plan and
execute your video and we'll be
announcing more things in the Futures to
give
you that was very eloquent at the end
particularly I'm I'm moved and we'll be
giving you more details as time goes on
like the thumbnail and the logo and the
websites and Etc and for those of you
who don't know much about the project
for awesome you'll find videos here here
here and here and you'll also find some
videos in the doo-doo part two a
challenge we would like to challenge you
nerd Feria last night at dinner Hank and
I were discussing pasta pasta and beef
everyone knows that it is far more
efficient in terms of energy output to
create pasta than it is to create beef
and that remains true even if you import
the pasta from say Italy but we were
wondering would this remain true if you
were importing the pasta from somewhere
farther away a save like the moon like
space so what we want to know is is it
more efficient to fly Apollo 11 to the
Moon pick up a loot of pasta fill up the
capsule entirely and then ship it back
would it then be more energy intensive
than growing a cow per calorie that is
our question we hope that there are some
of you who are nerdy and smart enough to
give us an accurate answer because we
couldn't figure it out no so we are
turning to you because you never
disappoint us nerd Feria if you
successfully determine for us whether
Moon pasta is more efficient than Earth
beef then we will allow you to challenge
us to do something horrible part three
the final announcement is that you may
have noticed that it is Black Friday so
in the spirit of the holidays dftba
records is lowering prices on some new
shirts and some old favorites are you
putting black I was trying to but your
head was too high the new shirts are the
giraffe love shirt why are the shirts on
my face because that's where they go two
new dftba shirts which we're calling the
dftba University shirts and the giant
squid of anger shirt designed by amazing
nerd fighter Von Del
swne all right so quick recap dftba.com
sale for all of your T-shirt needs is it
more efficient to have Moon pasta or
Earth burgers and the project for
awesome December 17th get ready and be
awesome dftba ner Fighters he'll see you
on
Monday I guess I'm teller
now hi there this is green and I'm Hank
Green and we are the Vlog Brothers on
YouTube and we are making this video a
frequently asked questions video for the
purposes of answering some questions
that are frequently Asked people are
often confused like for example what is
a nerd fighter a nerd fighter is a
person who instead of being made out of
like bones and skin and tissue is made
entirely of awesome so you're saying
that nerd Fighters don't fight nerds no
we're clearly Pro nerd nerd fighter is
basically just the community that sprung
up around our videos and basically we
just get together and try to do awesome
things things and have a good time and
fight against World suck what's World
suck World suck is kind of exactly what
world suck sounds like it's hard to
quantify exactly but you know it's like
the amount of suck in the world one of
the questions we get asked the most is
do you guys have real jobs yes well I
mean it depends on how you define real
Hank runs the environmental technology
website ecogeek John Green is an
award-winning author he has written
books such as Looking for Alaska and
abundance of Catherine in Paper Towns
and he's won many awards including the
Edgar award and the prince award why
don't you blink I don't blink because
I'm focusing when I'm in front of the
camera I do blink in real life that's
why I still have eyes and also it's sort
of a tribute to the original video
blogger our hero Z Frank so Hank what's
dftba dftba is an acronym no it isn't it
is not an acronym acronyms are
pronounceable it is an
initialism okay it's an initialism that
stands for don't forget to be awesome am
I too young old fat skinny weird cool
nerdy tall to be a nerd fighter no if
you want to be a nerd fighter you are a
nerd fighter nerd fighter dictionary
time lightning round puppy sized
elephants we asked natural selection to
make us puppy sized elephants because
they would have the evolutionary
advantage of being adorable and we are
waiting for that to happen stuff on
heads yeah if you put stuff on your head
it makes you feel better about life nerd
fighter Gatherings is when nerd Fighters
get together sometimes we're there
sometimes we're not French the Llama
French the Llama is something that John
is trying to make into a thing in which
people say French the Llama that whale
is big but it's not going to work oh
it's going to happen I'm going to make
French the Llama happen puff levels uh
my puff level is the level of puff in my
hair which gets higher as I get more
stressed out Decepticon is the opposite
of a nerd fighter giant squid of anger
it's basically like a YouTube
troll Tiny Chicken disease it is a
disease that happens when there's tiny
chickens in your head and they lay eggs
and all of it goo out of your nose it's
actually it's a common cold yeah secret
siblings secret siblings are anyone who
makes video responses down here to our
videos down here in my pants in your
pants in your pants is a phenomenon
discovered by Moren Johnson if you add
in yourr pants to the end of book titles
those book titles become much funnier
The Sun Also Rises in your pants a spot
of bother in your pants notom notum is
the opposite of awesome see also fail
puppy and the failboat the yeti is my
wife the Catherine is my wife oh and
this ah it's the nerd fighter gang sign
so if you see somebody doing this you
know that not to shoot them we have
created a playlist of 20 Vlog Brothers
videos that you can watch that will give
you a broader sense of what's going on
in nerd fighteria in case you're new and
if you have any friends that are a
little bit confused about why you're
watching two nerds make videos about
Star Wars and giraffe love and making
the world a better place through video
those those are three interconnected
ideas then you can send them to this
video right here so that they can get a
little bit of a debrief before plunging
in to the rest of our stuff now the
playlist is on the screen and we got to
do like a little playlist song playl
song playlist song playlist
song now did you just write that because
that's really good good morning Willie
do you guys want to see a
trick Panic I'm a bad person you're
going to be a great father
okay run for your life uh good morning
Hank good morning John today we're going
to talk about Christmas cuz it's
Christmas time it's almost Christmas
time I feel like the holiday season is
upon us like literally like like it is
preing upon us it is latched on like a
zombie yes controlling our every
movement certainly controlled my
movements in the last 48 hours because
all I've done is buy stuff Willie I'm
sorry about the Panic he doesn't care
he's forgotten about it yeah that's the
great thing about having a dog that's
the great thing about having a stupid
dog poor Willie he's so beautiful but
he's so stupid Willie will you be in the
thumbnail
thumbnail Hank and and I are both huge
fans of the Christmas season is that
fair to say that's fair to say I hate it
I love it I usually hate it but this
year I've gotten more into it because
we're expecting our first kid and you're
here and Katherine's here and Mom and
Dad are here and we've got this
beautiful Christmas tree because I'm So
Into Christmas this year I thought that
it would be appropriate to talk some
Christmas
facts gesticulation now what was the
first state to recognize Christmas as an
official holiday in the United States I
think it was Alabama it's almost like I
already told you this fact and you're
cheating but when John when in 1838 the
state of Alabama declared Christmas a
state holiday Christmas did not become a
national holiday in the United States
until 1870 so for almost the first 100
Years of our union Christmas was not
considered a national holiday but early
in American history there were fewer
national holidays right but also CH we
were busier right people had stuff to do
that's like inventing electricity but
then they had their evenings off due to
lack of light do you know anything about
hot cockal hot cockal is not for
contemporary life so one person is
blindfolded there are a bunch of people
in the room and then one of the people
who isn't blindfolded hits the person
who is blindfolded and then the
Blindfolded person has to guess who hit
them so if you want to be sneaky about
it you're like oh that was Sarah that
was definitely Sarah for some reason
Associated almost exclusively with
Christmas and why is it hot and cocko
why don't you do one John did you know
that Rudolph the Red-nose Reindeer was
invented by the Woolworth company I did
not know that because it's not true it
was Montgomery Ward maybe I should do
the facts Rudolph the rednose reindeer
was invented in the late 1930s by the
Montgomery Ward department store they
had one of their copywriters a guy named
Robert maze write a Christmas story and
because he was like a nerdy wimpy small
guy he decided to write a Christmas
story about a nerdy wimpy small reindeer
named Rudolph and then the story just
became massive because everybody loves a
nerdy reindeer if you're going to have a
reindeer you want a nerdy one in Canada
what is Santa's postal code I don't know
what what a Canadian postal codes look
like letter number letter number letter
number is it Le speak it is Le speak is
it h0 h0 h0 yes h0 h0 h0 okay I got one
Jingle Bells yes you know how that goes
Jingle Bells Batman Smells Robin Laden
before it was about Batman it was about
what Christmas Thanksgiving no way
really the Thanksgiving song which is
why it has no references to Christmas in
it are you sure yeah I'm going to check
that I'm gonna fact check wow roted in
1857 for a Thanksgiving program James
Lloyd Lord Pier Pont best known for
composing Jingle Bells but I mean to be
fair he should be famous for that beard
all right Hank here's the last Christmas
fact for you do you know all of the
words to the Jingle Bells Batman Smells
song I think I do Jingle Bells Batman
Smells Robin play an egg the batmobile
lost a wheel and Joker got away
hey happy holidays puff fight puff fight
ow my puff is stronger than your puff
hey I I've got an idea what's your idea
I want you to say good morning John and
then I'll be like good morning okay
that's I we've had that idea before I
know it's still funny though good
morning John good
morning a we're
[Music]
together
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a girl that on the dance FL and
I don't know how to reach her now
heterosexuality is not my defining
feature face have skinny jeans and
cardigan to the only way to go but now
it seems the o f employees are not the
ones who know just how it works give me
a minute while I fiddle with my hair if
you keep telling me that it looks fine
but I'm the one who care
about a good impression being made cuz
I'm the one who might get laid don't
tell me how the game is played don't
tell me how the game is played and I
don't want to talk to her and take her
hand in case you tells me her favorite
band is one my favorite band and how do
I know which drink she want me to buy
when do I look her in the eye when did
the music seem become so over fuss with
social inadequacy being such a must
don't knock me to the ground if I'm
already falling it'll only make things
worse you know I always do my calling
with the sage this evening is filling me
with rage I only wish I had some Sage
advice to give to me the Indie hook
volume 3 would reach your girls you
fancy them by getting with their
boyfriends your party loving mates with
aw grey CS who like listening to Sonic
you all always must appear aloof
remember no amount of Faking like your
Indie band groundbreaking oh don't think
you're special or much less of a
disgrace just because you got yourself a
lady who plays base don't bother finding
somebody to play disc and recorder yeah
that's not going to put you back in
working order you haven't got a
different sound you're on part of the
underground you haven't been together
long to try to ride some bloody de song
the girls outside now talking to a taxi
driver she were coming home with me it
only cost to my door IAL to her but I
sure she must have heard it all before
from guys though I could cry that's
probably the reason why he's dressed
just like a lesbian I hear it's quite a
crazy hardly move it pops for all the
lesbians these days but it hardly
matters if she's gay it's time to move
on anyway I'll see you guys till H out
10 tomorrow do it all
[Music]
again I wouldn't do that for
$1,000 I don't think I would enjoy that
either punishment that's a little too
high no that's not a funny punishment
punishment will make you to the frog
hopper be all over the place I literally
wouldn't do that for $1,000 I might not
do it for $10,000 I don't want to do
that at all oh good morning Hank good
morning John it's Wednesday I think
we're in Westport Connecticut we just
got to the hotel and we are unpacking
all of the current fighter gifts
including an extra large world's best
grandma shirt perfect size for John
Green well I don't know if you remember
the book but in the book it's too big so
it makes sense that it would be too big
but thanks for pointing out that I'm
[Music]
fat cows the Great American tour to nerd
fighting music Eco geeking and nerd
fighting Hank's passions Culver Creek
shirt Culver Creek Preparatory School
from Looking for Alaska just like Willie
he takes two steps barks for 10 minutes
and then takes two more
steps barking is
insane someone got us three hole catfish
wrap separately some vet sixpack of
Mountain Dew a dozen tulips a bottle of
water a box of tissues and a can of blue
spray paint paper TOS tour 11
1108 oh peeps oh peeps peeps oh peeps
fancy that yeah Amish frer bread Amish
hunger Wonder Bread Amish hunger Wonder
Bread it looks like this I'm going to
taste
it m amishi puppyz elephant piggy bank
don't put too much of your money in
there it's just like the American
economy oh empty Mystic kingdoms the
crumbling Towers in your pants team
zombie because I prefer the hard truths
of zombies to the easy lies of unicorns
puppy sized elephants rainbows it's all
so you can take it off and put other
stuff on too God I love rainbows nerd
duck that reminds me of Z yeah it does
definitely remind me of Z this says that
I'm the chairman of awesome chairman
chairman it's a special Christmas
ornament for Willie oh that's cute it's
Willie look nerdy cereal and then on the
back some Shakespearean insults thou
mangled hedge born Punk this person says
Nery is also a great thing to put on
your head I went to finishing school and
I learned how to do this that's what you
learned in finishing school I certainly
didn't learn how to dance because no one
would dance with me at at Crown school
for
dancing the only semi-autobiographical
thing in Paper Towns I love these
scrunch scrunch that a Fresno lens it is
that's awesome lens really good for
focusing sunlight on ants also on solar
panels oh really it's very
confusing okay well that's it I haven't
gathered anything for the last several
how do I look other than awesome I mean
fun Housey great white wall of cow
that's
hilarious wouldn't that be great if if
the Wonka company would recognize how
much more awesome nerds would be if they
call them fighting nerds oh it's a go
fast
bar I'm going to eat it oh I want to eat
it sorry you can have some Amish hunger
wonderer bread it's delicious too and
look Han it's bubbles the nerd fighting
puppy that's like an exact replica his
cast he's a cute little guy it's almost
life siiz I miss you Willie who's going
to pee on the floors in the hotel room
without you just me it all falls to me I
have to make the mess and clean it up
when you're around you can do the peeing
on the floor for
me I do miss him man it's crazy when the
stuff that you imagine becomes real it
is very
[Music]
gratifying
oh okay I got it I got it I got it I got
it party blower so low good morning Hank
you're in the hotel room right next to
me so I should probably just say good
morning nerd Fighters and welcome to a
day in our life on tour first the iPhone
alarm clock goes off at some ungodly
hour in the
morning then I brushed my teeth while
trying to answer questions about my hair
such as how did that happen then I meet
up with Hank and the Catherine in the
hallway good morning
mister talking about fun house oh yeah
cheetah
time Library elevator the mouse is
hungry for knowledge time to load up the
minivan and then we
drive while our friend Ellen tells us
how to get where we're
going oh traffic you're so funny to get
stuck in sometimes I strain to
appreciate natural beauty while cars
drive past look natural beauty a truck
stupid
truck stupid crane I'm trying to
appreciate natural beauty then I live
broadcast myself on blog tv.com while
inside the minivan due to Hank's
miraculous Contraption hello me how are
you doing I need to help I can see my
eyes in my eyes and then we'll just be
having a perfectly polite conversation
and Catherine will be like have you guys
ever wondered about cows she's so good
at
cows they come out of nowhere you got to
be
ready and finally we arrive in
Pittsburgh whereupon I begin to
contemplate how I will pone Moren
Johnson hey Moren hey why are we mortal
enemies because because everywhere you
go John you cross my name out of bled
snow and you sign my books can't we just
um like have a
truce I suppose we could I mean I'm sure
that there are some all right
[Music]
oh
hi wow but really wouldn't you worry I
mean we've been dating for 5 weeks and
he's never taken me to his house now
give me
my
then late at night we get to a hotel I
go to bed and then I wake wake up early
the next morning and do it all again it
would be tiring if nerd Fighters weren't
so incredibly awesome and also if I
didn't keep getting amazing shirts like
this Culver Creek t-shirt complete with
a swan nerd Fighters I look forward to
seeing many of you in Kansas City and St
Paul Hank I'll see you in the morning
and so it begins the Great American
Jordan nerd fighting 2008 featuring Hank
John the Catherine and the
[Music]
minivan
good morning Hank it's Monday and I am
driving a minivan through the great
state of Missouri I am in fact driving
the exact same minivan that Q's mom owns
in Paper Towns which is one of the
reasons that we picked it for the Great
American tour to nerd fighting 2008 by
the way when I say good morning Hank I
mean it good morning Hank good morning
John thanks for filming my Vlog for me
today I'm going to edit it too so you
sound like an
idiot we are driving right now on our
our way to a nerd fighter gathering in
St Louis yesterday we were in both Plano
Texas and Oklahoma City Oklahoma both
those Gatherings were awesome and we
announced the release of Hank's first
studio album so jokes cue the music it's
too
hot it's too hot in here I need Harry
Potter like a gy love needs water I want
to
book oh Helen Hunt Helen Hunt you make
my heart to acrobatic stunts we listened
to the whole thing yesterday it's just
amazing it's only for sale on the tour
to nerd fighting sorry if you're not
coming to a nerd fighter Gathering but
if you are you got to pick up a CD they
cost $15 and no we cannot take credit
cards also in Plano Texas we met Sean
ammed the guy from Bangladesh who has
been working with save the children to
make the world suck less through our
money and we'll be collecting money for
save the children of Bangladesh
throughout the entire tour you guys want
to hear something crazy a guy comes up
to me me at the nerd fighter gathering
in Oklahoma City and he says I have a
copy of Looking for Alaska that is
unlike any other copy of Looking for
Alaska in the world and I was like oh
yeah sure whatever he held it out it was
half eaten and he said this copy of
Looking for Alaska was half eaten by a
Hawaiian Mongoose and I was like okay
full points I totally believe him
because he looked like the kind of guy
who did professionally wrestle Hawaiian
monges it's been a lot of sitting in the
car with Katherine and Hank although
that's been a lot of fun uh Catherine
and Hank are excellent company in a
minivan we missed the yeti
but we do keep her right here hello
Yeti I'm coming home to you tomorrow for
the election day spectacular in
Greenwood Indiana after that we will be
in Louisville Kentucky then we'll be in
Knoxville Tennessee and then we'll be in
gadston Alabama the spiraling shape will
make you go insane that's the best part
of being on a road trip with me joh gets
to sing then he drives over the rumble
strip rumble strips Rumble R strips
rumble strips are my favorite part of
driving I love the sound of a rumble
strip it makes my butt vibrate I know
but that's good you got to get the Deep
Vin thrombosis out I love you
Missouri dang it Katherine and I have
this friendly competition about who is
going to spot cows first and she's up
like 888 million to one I think we
should like quit riding and Eco geek and
just do this fulltime buy a minivan
travel around the country meet nerd
Fighters
spew carbon dang it how where oh cows in
the distance I heard they were like 3
miles away nerd Fighters Mak me believe
in America again why don't you close out
the Vlog Hank Hank I'll see you tomorrow
P.S there's an tour to nerd fighting
Twitter stream which will be constantly
broadcasting updates from the road I
have this extraordinarily exciting
device here which lets me be on the
internet want I'm in a minivan damn it
cows I am so bad at cows
and John and I will be broadcasting all
of the nerd fighter Gatherings on Blog
TV there's a link in the sidebar for
both the Twitter and the Blog TV oh
horses it was not cows I thought I had
it but it was
[Music]
[Applause]
horses good morning Hank it's Thursday
good morning John that's the big
surprise that's the big surprise it's
still up still the two of us just
kidding there's another surprise well I
think a good surprise is that we're
doing a video together yeah actually so
it's not really good morning Hank good
morning John it's more morning nerd
Fighters that was yes completely not
we're on fire we didn't even scrip that
that was so improvised today's video
comes in two parts first we are going to
answer some frequently asked questions
and secondly we are going to talk about
the exciting secret
project Hank I can't tell the two of you
apart which one is which I'm John I'm
Hank and I'm the yeti why do they call
her the yeti John it's because she's so
hairy Hank she is so hairy oh my God
it's amazing it's all over her face I
would hate like to clean your drains why
is there an eye missing in communication
in the animated intro uh it's because
there is no eye in Brotherhood but why
is there no eye in communication um
because there's no eye in shut the up I
want to become a nerd fighter how do you
become a nerd fighter uh if you want to
become a nerd fighter you probably
already are a nerd fighter technically
you should go to Brotherhood 2.com and
write a song but in all likelihood you
my friend are a nerd fighter and like 3
months ago that would have sucked but
now it's awesome somehow how do you
become a Secret sibling to become a
Secret sibling all you have to do is
make a video response to one of our
videos on YouTube preferably several
responses in a row every day remember
like in January you guys said that you
were going to make a happy dance
compilation whatever happened to that uh
we didn't do it um I don't know if
you've noticed this Hank but there's
like 70 million abandoned Brotherhood
2.0 projects along the way I mean
question Tuesdays question Tuesdays
question Tuesdays didn't even have a
second appearance no it was just the one
question the giving away of my tote bags
but there is another answer to this
question and that brings us to the
exciting secret project which is about
not to be secret anymore notice how I
didn't split the infinitive John and I
are asking and the nerd fighters to help
us create the happy dance project Hank
and I were sitting around the other day
and we said to each other you know what
would be more awesome than if we made a
happy dance compilation video if all of
the nerd Fighters sent us their happy
dances dancing in front of their awesome
places in their towns and neighborhoods
and then we made a happy dance
compilation video using all nerd fighter
happy dances because you know that nerd
Fighters have a lot of crazy happy
dances I mean we've seen some happy
dances and some secret sibling videos
crazy happy dances I mean these videos
are so crazy and sexy and cool they
could be a TLC album
Word excellent use of word some quick
rules about the happy dance videos we
hope you'll send us please make them
about 10 seconds long not too much
longer because otherwise our computers
will explode also please send them to
sparksfly up
gmail.com you probably need a deadline I
know you people you like to
procrastinate October 1st
October 1st at the very latest but if
you have your Halloween costumes already
put them on it would be great if
everyone could organize to make sure
that there's a happy dance in front of
like the seven major wonders of the
world so if we could have someone hit
the Hanging Gardens of Babylon that
would be very helpful because uh we are
going to have a tough time getting to
Babylon you might have wanted to choose
one of the major wonders of the world
that still exists get to the pyramids oh
by the way if you're new to this and
wondering what a happy dance is it's the
dance that you do when you're incred
happy here's two
examples see that was way less than 10
seconds dir
fighs that's how we
[Music]
[Applause]
roll good morning John it's Monday June
11th good morning Hank
yes show me that smile show me that
smile don't BL
another it on you crying we no
near near the best is ready to
be
oh as long as we got each
other we got the world sping in our
hands baby you and me we got to be the
luckiest dreamers who never quit
dreaming as long as we keep on
giv we can take anything that comes our
way with be rain or shine all the time
we got each other sharing the laughter
in
[Music]
love
what are we doing Hank um laying on the
beach in of all places the Dominican
Republic uh at a family reunion and
what's the most exciting part of the
family reunion so far the the reunion of
the Brotherhood
John why don't we do it like this every
day where is Catherine she's stuck in
Montana at work which really sucks well
it would suck except that she's doing
weed research well yeah I guess it's
nice that she has a job but it's very
sad that she isn't here even though you
have a Yeti wave hi to Catherine hi
Catherine we miss you Catherine we miss
you John I will see you in a couple of
minutes in the great tradition of
Brotherhood 2.0 special features here
are some outakes good morning
John it's Monday June
11th we made a lot of money guys
a are you what happened I did a testicle
flop be the first person to ever drown
of testical
pain [__] I'm sorry I'm thought I'm in a
fetal position you can't pant kind of
burned my
eye
that's very
good wow